just in case you can also ping me if I
start to move around because that's one
of my biggest issues
Jeffrey did you watch the Dallas game
yesterday
oh Mavs played wait sorry I can't hear
you uh uh I probably because
all are you speaking
let me let me message all on Slack
okay wait let me replace
so Donna you can't hear me right now
okay
um
okay now my audio is definitely working
okay can you hear me no I can hear you
yes perfect perfect sorry about that
no problem freaking Bose headphones are
annoying
they changed my yeah they changed like
the audio all the time for no entire
reason
um
but yeah I did not I I assume you asked
you were asking about the Mavs game
[Music]
foreign
mm-hmm
ings
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
within the Tempest the best have come to
test their skills and brave the storm oh
we missed it oh
my goodness the wheels the wheels have
come out that could be the magic for
some this is familiar ground oh my
goodness 98 whoa
for others this is a Fresh Field to
prove their prowess this is insane oh
look at Fabby exhausting every last
resource the battles will be Electric
Al tactic the moves will be fast
game over it's winning oh my God yes it
is he's gonna make a queen the stakes
will be high he just grabs his head he
can't believe it he just gave away the
pawn the 2022 speed Chess Championship
is now
fasten your speed belts my friends we're
in for a wild ride
you can ship another day another very
exciting match for you today and it is a
pleasure bringing you this match I'm
your host Grandmaster Daniel nerdinski
alongside me today the one and only
Grandmaster Jeffrey Shang my good friend
JX how you feeling
okay
hello good morning Donya good morning
chat I'm feeling excited for today's
match I think it's gonna be
fireworks from the very start expect
much closer uh when then yesterday's
match so yeah I'm just looking forward
some guy named Magnus Carlson was
slightly lopsided but let's start from
the beginning what is at seek the main
event prize pool folks is a
mouth-watering one hundred thousand
dollars and most importantly uh the very
Innovative aspect of the prize fund is
that a large portion of it is split
based on win percentage so even if the
result of the match is decided which I
don't think it won't I don't think it
will be today up until the very end but
quite a large amount is split based on
who wins how many games Jeffrey do you
think that partially stands behind the
scc's success
oh yeah absolutely I know myself from
playing these events that the prize is
also just increase as you go along so I
see 4K already for the first match which
is a hefty sum but imagine if you get
all the way to the finals like this is
life-changing money already
it most certainly is a lot of cars can
be bought with that kind of money and
speaking of cars or not speaking of cars
let's read the bracket and let's see
what damage has been done so far it's
really A Feast for the eyes as you see
Magnus Carlson top right doing away with
kukesh that was yesterday 23-7 yeah 23-7
you can just say that to yourself a
couple of times aronian beats on draken
that was our first overtime that went
all the way to Armageddon and of course
dingley ran grishook another very close
match on the bottom left Jeffrey it
doesn't even it doesn't even matter
where you go you've got fascinating
matches all around
yeah what a thriller that was uh on
Drake and aronian went down to the wire
the origin match as well
was incredible
um but right now I want to say like a
lot of people feel like this is a
collision course
um where Hikaru is going to meet Magnus
but I just want to bring the attention
to all the other guys here I mean mvl
how impressive was he first of all
against nepo
and uh ding he he says he wants to say
hello in India in the corner so yeah I
mean just to mention a couple guys this
a lot of players can make noise here oh
they most certainly can and yeah ding is
by the way playing for a world
championship so uh he ain't just gonna
go gentle into that good night but
neither are the players today we have
Grandmaster nihal Sarah and the Phenom
from India in an cgc rematch against
Anish giri and if you have anything
except a short memory you will remember
that nihal saran defeated Anish in their
fascinating cgc match that went all the
way to overtime and all the way to an
Armageddon so JX these players are
fascinating to watch on their own but
add to that the fact that they've just
had a hotly contested match for a ton of
money Anisha is definitely gonna have a
chip on the shoulder Yeehaw always has a
chip on his shoulder how can this be
anything but fascinating
oh my God yeah you bring up that GCC
match it was an absolute nail biter
could not have been closer honestly I
remember following it um and as you said
Geary he might have some Revenge uh in
mind today I I'm sure he'll use that as
motivation
um but yeah as you said like in general
this match any match that pits you know
the old guard against sort of the new
generation Peaks my interest I think
we've already seen a couple of Piers of
nihal go down so he's gonna try to
redeem bring some some glory to to the
young Indian prodigies over there yeah
and nihal's compatriot argentary guy see
losing his first round matchup against
Fabiano caruana so you mentioned old
guard against new guard that might
necessitate an Anish giri tweet uh that
comment alone uh not sure what Anish is
doing right now something tells me he's
got Twitter open uh as at least one of
his Taps but before we jump into the
mesh let's go over uh the format one
more time we remind you that the SCC is
a 16 player knockout a couple of players
I've been knocked out already player
score points across three-time controls
until time runs out and those three time
controls are 90 minutes of five plus one
followed by an hour of three plus one
and the match concludes with 30 minutes
of one plus one and we've seen so many
matches decided in the bullet Jeffrey
it's an elegant format it's a simple
format it's easy to follow and it
produces some nail biting chess
absolutely and I want to point out the
psychological Factor here is the bullet
section because I think a lot of players
who are in the know of chess
uh have an idea of just how dangerous
nehal is in faster time controls and I
believe Anish will also be aware of this
so when you know that in bullet uh your
opponent is capable of running up the
score that puts a lot of pressure on him
to maybe try and compensate in blitz so
that's the one X Factor I'd like to
point out here
the anisha's performance especially in
the five plus one well speaking of X
factors and performances predicted
performances let's ask smarter chess who
he thinks is going to win this match and
each individual section you see the
prediction there it's about as close as
it can possibly get it's modern chess is
predicting a one point win for nihal
sarin with a 57 win probability I mean
that's just crazy and I think that's
incredibly accurate I've made my name
criticizing smarter chess and you
criticize smarter chess Jeffrey for
predicting a close match like this I
think that's what we all think is going
to happen I absolutely agree with the
final prediction
but I would favor Geary more in five
minutes at least by one point and I'd
give nehal more of an edge in that
bullet section which I already mentioned
I feel like he just has more experience
there with the Mouse
um and yeah I mean I could be wrong on
this but I I'd give neho like up to
three point Edge there in bullet
yeah and he's faster than the mouse he's
ridiculously tricky I mean you've seen
we've all seen by now the amount of
totally lost positions that nihal
manages to pull out the moment things
get down to a Time scramble in our
community predicts a similar kind of
layout with 54 choosing nihal sarin to
win 46 correspondingly choosing Anish
giri and a lot of total brackets it's
been great to see the community
engagement just how many people are
filling out brackets how many are doing
so accurately and you know the community
really adds that kind of magical element
to the SCC and really makes this all
about rooting for your favorite player
Jeffrey again I would say a very
reasonable take here uh by the community
what would you say
yeah I I again I think everybody's on
the same page here with Neil being just
the slight favorite I only the thing
with the bracket though I only wish mine
was doing better I've only gotten two
right so far so safe to say I'm out of
the contest for this year but it is nice
to see all the participation in
whichever I was out of the contest from
like minute one somehow I mean just the
concept of a bracket in general whether
it's college basketball or chess I have
had terrible luck filling in Brackets
just gonna put that out there that's why
I'm remaining a commentator okay before
the games begin let's take a quick look
at the two players this chess.com Blitz
insights we have a lot of interesting
stats here Jeffrey LV makes sense of
this
yeah I mean
the thing that jumps out is the games
played like the experience the online
experience nearly 19
000 yes 19 000 against just under 600
for uh for a niche
that I mean it goes without saying like
in bullet you need the the mouse
experience the interface pre-moving all
those skills and abilities that nehal
has and we'll see where where Anish can
can compensate that
yeah and I think you actually she
brought up a point that's far from
obvious which I totally agree with which
is that when you talk about overall lack
of experience that really comes in the
shorter the time control five plus one
anybody could play I mean even gukesh
was riding along with Magnus yesterday
at least for like three games
um but you didn't really feel the lack
of experience until the three plus one
and especially the bullet that's where
all the mechanics come in and that's
where anxiety really comes in with
players who don't play online regularly
now
some players uh Jeffrey might not
realize that Anish giri actually kind of
grew up playing in the park my friend
Vladimir fredev described him as a park
player he played a lot of Blitz over the
board in his childhood so he's not a bad
Blitz player he just might not be as
familiar with the sort of mechanics of
online chess and I think that
distinction has to be made would you
agree with that
for sure and
the one thing about neho is when he gets
low on time he never panics while Other
Guys Like Me Maybe maybe Anisha as well
in the time scramble they're just
focusing on not flagging not even paying
any attention to the position anymore so
it could be a big decisive Factor
um and perhaps problematic which is why
again I think the bullet section is
going to be the main concern here for
Anish
agreed and it's also one of the big
reasons nihal is so fun to watch he gets
down to just ridiculous times on the
clock in ridiculously complex positions
and manages to make sense of it it's one
of the most tilting things about facing
nihal you think you got him you think
you've got him down to three seconds and
sometimes he could even be losing we saw
that in his match again in the cgc
against Sam Sevin and by now I think
everybody's familiar with nihal saran's
Antics I mean Jeffrey we've both played
him so many times by now online he's
just a force to be reckoned with
yeah I you don't need to you don't need
to remind me on that uh
apologies
I'll get his card there
so
we I mean we should also mention that he
just won the uh taught to steal rapid so
he's got an over the board resume
um on top of the second place at GC of
course and mult two-time jscc champion
so the accolades go on and on for niho
you and it's so crazy in chess how you
can just be 18 and you can already build
up a resume like this we could almost
refer to him as a veteran definitely of
online chess maybe not as much over the
board and that's something people have
been expecting from nehal for a while
now nobody doubts that he's going to
cross 2700 uh but he's already made such
a name for himself in the realm of
online Blitz I mean
it's just it's just crazy how much he's
already achieved and we'll continue to
achieve and I agree with a pragmatic
style strength Jeffrey for somebody
who's 18 he's incredibly Universal he
can basically do a little bit of
everything
and what we saw from that GCC match I
think against Denise which I'm sure will
reference a few times today he really
focused on just playing real chess his
main agenda was let me get out of uh
anisha's opening book
play just play the game and see what
happens and it did work out for him in
the end
that's I'm expecting more of the same
Trend here today
agreed I mean we're probably going to
see a good amount of London systems
Anish of course has hung his hat in many
cases on some incredible opening
preparation really from the very
beginning of his chess career and our
chest.com team has decided that his
biggest strength based on his insights
as we look at his player card is his
toughness and that's a very under I mean
there's a lot of really underrated
aspects of Anish giri's player makeup
and Jeffrey we like to joke you know the
draw the draw thing let's put all that
aside nishikiri has belonged to the
World Elite for well over a decade now
and you don't do that by accident
no you don't and the toughness is an
interesting thing that's not the first
thing I thought of uh when I think of
Anish Geary I would think of I would
think of amazing opening prep like
innovative ideas from the get-go
and also just a tremendous understanding
of the game I've always been uh enamored
by his positional understanding I feel
like when he gets his positions he can
turn it into an absolute Master Quest
and I'm looking forward to seeing it uh
today
yeah he had some crazy cgc games the one
kind of eyesore out of this inside card
of course is his SCC match record I mean
two wins and five losses something that
Anish giri is going to try to rectify
it's going to take him a while to
rectify it but if he does well this time
around he could reverse that record
do you think that that actively eats at
him Jeffrey or do you think these
players they play so many different
types of tournaments that they don't
really care about their record in one
particular event where do you think
yeah I think his SEC record is somewhere
in the in the back of his mind like he's
not gonna lose sleep over that but
on the other hand it it does get in your
head a little bit like when you know
there's a certain event that you just
never seem to do well at and uh his
opponent today not necessarily a
cakewalk so hopefully it doesn't
doesn't uh eat away at him but it should
be a good match nonetheless it really
should interestingly the chat is picking
Anish giri by a healthy margin in our
chat poll to win the five plus one
section and if we bring this back uh to
what we started the discussion with and
by the way we are getting ready to start
the games nihal having some difficulties
with his computer but he's rebooting
we'll get this match on the road very
shortly but Anish giri has to put
through a really powerful performance in
the five plus one I think he's got to
build that three or four point question
if they get into the bullet and the
match is tied Jeffrey I said the same
thing in the aronian on draken Match on
draken ended up being up three points
and he and he ends up losing that match
that was just crazy so what do you know
but I think the hall is more stable in
bullet than even Dimitri on Dragon
yeah this reminds me back in the day
there was a jscc match between Wei and
furuja and everyone was making the same
take more or less that way you needed a
huge lead going into the bullet but as
it turned out he ended up winning that
bullet second but like four or five
alireza tilted in that match so the
truth is you never really know when it
comes to SEC and you might want to
expect the unexpected in a sense
and I think part of the reason that is
is because of the increment I think a
lot of people really vastly
underestimate the role that the
increment plays I uh when I was trying
to get into the SEC I had a match
against Daniel dubov I was leading by
like four points going into the the mini
bullets segment and I lost the first
four games and Jeffrey I felt like I was
playing a completely different game it
felt totally different from one plus
zero when you get down to low time
controls that one second increment I'm
sure you could co-sign this point uh
really turns it into a bit of a
different game
it's it's night and day for one plus
zero honestly like it's it's even
confusing in a way because it doesn't
feel like bullet like you can even play
slow at times just to keep your position
stable and then at some point as long as
you turn on the Jets you're never ever
gonna flag so yeah and I know I know how
you feel uh when you say
that you're just Shell Shocked
um in a certain temperature where you
feel advantageous and all of a sudden
that's not the way it's going so yeah I
mean just uh confusing time control to
say the least why is he playing so fast
why is he playing so well and I've also
played knee-haul a lot in this weird
time control 10 seconds to start the
game plus a one second increment that's
actually a good time control to practice
for the uh SCC and he is an absolute
force to be reckoned with in that time
control so I think nihal is going to try
to play long games he's gonna try to
bring as many games as possible down to
a Time scramble and we're gonna see a
lot into vintage nihal sarin comebacks
today but Anish I mean he's so solid
he's so well prepared in the opening and
the opening is a phase of the game
Jeffrey that nihal did have his share of
struggles with again in the cgc and the
reason I keep mentioning the cgc is that
that is the hall saran's last big event
so you know that's what's going to be
circular relating around his mind he got
some bad positions of the white pieces
he played a lot of London systems do you
think we're going to see any drastic
changes from nehal or will there be more
of the same with the white pieces
I Envision him mixing it up a lot I
think he will this is what he generally
likes to do uh as far as I remember when
I commented on his jscc matches at least
he'll open with as you said a lot of
londons you'll go with the I think
Knight F3 B3 setup as well
just token prod everywhere in
try and find something that works
eventually
yeah Knight F3 B3 is kind of the Hikaru
approach uh just kind of I mean I would
say the London used to fulfill that role
but now it's gotten so theoretical that
you can't really play the London anymore
to avoid Theory but we saw nihal putting
together some really weird setups he had
a bishop on E3 at one point he was
grabbing that pawn on C5 and then trying
to cling to it so I'm always excited
what uh the players bring to the table
uh in in their SEC matches and Jeffrey
they very wildly on whether they prepare
I mean I think some players they take
the SEC as seriously as a classical
event they spend hours preparing others
and I have a feeling nihal might air on
that side it's not that he doesn't take
it seriously but you just kind of want
to be fresh going into it
yeah honestly that would sum me up
pretty well uh when you said somebody
who takes this as seriously as classical
I try to come in
um with as much ammunition as I could
but I always found like the moment the
match starts you can throw all of that
out the window I I always forget what I
prepare and at the end of the day it
just comes down to playing good moves on
the board like so many there's so many
factors in the game of chess
that the opening is simply not going to
decide the game
and would you say as somebody who's
competed in the SEC you know I sometimes
get this feeling before a title Tuesday
speaking of title Tuesday I forgot who
won the late title Tuesday yesterday
with some guy
uh who's I heard is a pretty decent
commentator but we won't talk about that
right now you've also played in the SEC
do you feel the butterflies in your
stomach like sometimes these big online
events I personally feel a kind of
anxiety that I don't even feel over the
board do you kind of know what I'm
talking about
oh totally I remember my first jscc I
was so worried going into the bullet
that I wouldn't even be able to escape
execute the moves my my hand was just
shaking profusely and it feels like
every time you need to warm yourself up
into the match I think the nerves are
spinning out of control at the very
start and this is why a lot of players
take time to really get themselves into
the match
yeah for sure and they spin out of
control in the end as well for those of
you just joining folks uh we are working
through some of nehal's tech issues
we're making progress so the match
should be underway any second but for
now we're just kind of hanging out
talking about these two amazing players
you're watching the speed Chess
Championship were still in the round of
16 and
um nihal sarin I mean if he wins this
match let's go back for a second to the
bracket and talk about the path that
these players have to take even if they
manage to win Jeffrey the SEC is
absolutely brutal as you just look at
these names the winner has to face some
guy named dingley Wren yeah
pretty easy match
yeah you've got ding lady in the wings
um
I just look around okay obviously the
the Carlson Carolina's is the juiciest
um the rematch from world champion not
really uh don't really need an
introduction to that but yeah I mean
just everywhere it's amazing matchups
tomorrow I think there's a double header
so tons of excitement coming up
yeah tomorrow we have Wesley so against
Notre back abdusutarov to determine who
plays MBL that's lower right side of
your screen and then upper left side we
have some dude named Hikaru Nakamura
against the qualifier David paravian by
the way not the easiest match for Hikaru
I know a lot of people are thinking of
this kind of like they did Carlson
gukesh but David varavian is is a
different kettle of fish entirely he is
a lot more experience of an online
player and Jeffrey I think by now we
know how important that is
yeah that is it is it feels like the big
thing now just being experienced and he
plays in every title Tuesday you see him
in all the the rccs in the past all
these online things so he knows his way
around
uh online chess and he's gonna give
Hikaru as big of a fight as he can
yeah he most certainly is and he's got
that gritty opening preparation and when
all of the eyes are on you everybody's
expecting you to win everybody's
expecting Perfection it can produce some
interesting effects I thought it was
interesting uh Jeffrey that Magnus
yesterday was incredibly disappointed
with this play I mean he was not in a
good mood in the interview and the guy
wins by 16 points what is he going to
win by when he actually plays to his
satisfaction that's a pretty scary
thought isn't it let me tell you if I
beat gookish by 16 that's definitely not
my reaction yeah
yeah like I feel I guess he said that he
didn't feel like he got into form at all
in any point of the match so
yeah we'll see how it goes against
against Fabiano I think
even the the bitter Truth uh
unfortunately for the rest of us is even
in magnus's worst form is usually still
better than us so it is it can be
depressing let's say it's incredibly
depressing yeah he can miss every tactic
in the book and somehow he's still
winning by a thousand points folks as we
continue to work through uh some tech
issues on nihals and we're doing uh
doing it as quickly as we can but we are
going to go on a short break please
don't go anywhere you will not want to
miss this match between nehal and a
nation what's it once it gets underway
we are going to have non-stop
entertainment so folks we will be right
back with the start of yet another
incredible round of 16 SEC match stay
tuned
just played an exciting game and want to
see if you got a brilliancy or maybe
where you could have improved
chess.com's game review is just a click
away game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com's coach who gives
move explanations opening statistics and
shows you the best lines of play
with retry mistakes you can get another
shot at finding missed opportunities
try game review today on web iOS or
Android
foreign
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the speed Chess
Championship we have good news ladies
and gentlemen the match between the
hulsarin and Anish Gary is about to get
underway the issues have been fixed here
alongside Grand Master Jeffrey Zhang
Jeffrey 90 minutes of five plus one we
finally see the players on camera there
keeping my fingers crossed
indeed the apologies for the delay uh
but it's great to see both of them
when I whenever I see niho show up it it
always seems like he just woke up I
don't know if it if you share the same
impression
I do and I think I'm pretty well attuned
to what players look like when they've
just woken up because I remember a
couple of matches you know maybe toward
uh the the first half of the day maybe
at three or four pm
that I uh I used to have my my laptop
right next to my right next to my bed so
it was the perfect setup I could wake up
running my computer
log into chess.com in just a couple of
seconds I had the routine all worked out
yeah yeah gotcha and Anish I maybe not
too thrilled about about the wait time
probably was wondering what's going on
but it is great that uh we have resolved
those problems and should be getting
underway shortly
yeah Niche always has a very Sleek setup
I think he's playing from home
and uh Eindhoven City in the Netherlands
okay seat belts fastened folks the games
should begin literally any second not
sure who will have the white pieces at
first that's actually one piece of SCC
lore that I should be familiar with but
I'm not how do they decide who gets
white in the very first game
I think they always give it to the high
rated piracy I'm not mistaken right
which in this case is nihal because he's
the higher seed that's important to
realize his online rating is actually
higher
yeah that is an interesting Dynamic uh
Anish
barely Head and Shoulders above Still In
classical but online is another story
and finally we do have a good club here
we go you're right nehal has the white
pieces in game one and already a big
decision from the very start what is he
going to play what Sidelines is he going
to trot out well there's our answer a
trumpowski in game one from nehal
yeah and that is not something I see
niho traditionally play I feel like he
was exclusively London but this is gonna
be up his alley anyway he's gonna uncork
what I think is like a tourist setup
yeah and the Tori setup is basically the
London with the bishop on G5 rather than
F4 which does change the nature of the
position in some ways Jeffrey the
drawback is that it allows 94 with Tempo
in some cases but the plus side is that
you can take on F6 whenever you want
you're applying pressure on Black's King
side
yeah and I would have actually
considered taking it right now just to
see which way Blackbird captures you
double the Pawns and even though you
give the bishop air you get this sort of
imbalance where maybe white would be
slightly easier to navigate
just Bishop F6 ASAP
I've often seen black recapture with the
g-pawn and then try to go for E5 Anish
actually encourages that I would imagine
that he will take on F6 now no he's
still
keeps the bishop alive interesting I'm a
little bit surprised it is very curious
to me which Pawn did Denise intend on
recapturing like if you take with the
epon you'd be left with the isolated
d-pawn but gf6 didn't look right there
either so a bit of a moment where I'm
not sure what the players were thinking
because now Jeffrey correct me if I'm
wrong it feels like after E6 black has
kind of an ideal exchange caracon setup
where you've gotten the bishop outside
the pawn chain okay nihal is trying to
poke in prod
at the queen side but I don't feel like
this is such a dangerous idea Queen C7
maybe even Queen B6 can be considered
here for black
I feel like the more standard response
is Queen C8 just to avoid everything
like Queen C7 maybe there could be a
bishop G3 sighting so
uh and also I guess Queen B6 would allow
the Double B puns not sure if you want
to see that either so I'm expecting
Queen C8 and assuming that Anish really
doesn't mind the the doubled pawns after
Bishop takes F6
yeah and given that he played H6 earlier
it seems like he does any plans oh he's
a very creative move A6
and let's bring up our first analysis
Board of the day folks do not take this
Pawn
because of Knight A5 that's the idea of
A6 covering the B5 Square wow nehal sees
it Jeffrey what a surprise
yeah very subtle trap uh set there by a
niche don't be uh fooled by these super
GMS they do know a thing or two about
Chess
and after Bishop B7 you once again
cannot take on B7 for the same reason
notice that the bishop cuts off the
Queen's access to F7
and it just seems like nehal is he's
playing moves that look good on the
surface but
Gary is totally unperturbed and if he
can Castle we could start talking about
a slight Edge for black here pretty
quickly
yeah it does feel like this 95 jump more
of a paper paper tiger as you like to
say
um and yeah as you said I'm not happy
with this position for niho I don't see
any great ideas like if you go Bishop V2
black is just gonna castle at some point
if Black Goes Knight takes E5 and like
uh Knight G4 for instance that E5 Pawn
could be difficult to to protect
you're absolutely right and you often
don't want to play F4 in these types of
positions and weaken the king side even
further okay an interesting
transformation Yeehaw grabs the Knight
on C6 and follows up with Queen A4 so
he's basically I think trying to play
against black sweet dark squares on the
queen side we might see a knight B3 move
what do you make of this Jeffrey wow and
he just grabs the pawn on C6 no fear
fear yeah that U of R dropped uh
immediately 94 I was expecting like a
queen A5 or or Rook V8 there just
getting quick play uh on the queen side
potentially this is also an interesting
approach where he swaps everything and
at some point he's gonna go Rook seed
and Rook B8
and I think a lot of people would
hesitate to play 94 because it leads to
an exchange of several minor pieces and
you're a pawn down but if you think
about it after a 94 Bishop before you've
got plenty of material with which to
attack and I think you called it he
wants one Rook on B8 the other Rook on
C8 the queen is obviously on a very
awkward spot this is not how nihal
envisioned starting things off he's in
trouble here he's in he's in serious
trouble
and it is very important to note that
that Bishop F5 is controlling the B1
Square so
there's no easy way for white to protect
B2 which I imagine is the reason why a
niho is spending some time here
yeah he doesn't want to take on e4 and
allow this bishop to move into an ideal
spot you certainly don't want to go F3
after that to create even more
weaknesses on your king side
so what comes to mind here he does take
on e4 and he does play F3 so
you waited for me to say that yeah
just to taunt you yeah
um All About taunting commentators
but here's the thing
I don't think you can cast along like
I'm trying to understand how does he
want to protect that B2 Pawn I'm so
worried about Rook B8 next
and you never can play B3 because then
C3 would be too weak of a point no Rook
be one
long Castle I mean that just looks like
suicide so I don't know how to deal with
this threat no this is really really
annoying and one instance of it is after
Bishop B2 as you said Bishop B2 Rook AB8
and I mean you can see the evil bar
dropping even further it's not an
exaggeration to say that white is
borderline lost here E3 Rook FCA and
Jeffrey I think it should be pointed out
that even in a scenario where white
manages to Castle kingside he doesn't
necessarily solve all of his problems
you still have a weakness on D4 you
still have a massive initiative on the
queen side so these problems are pretty
long lasting you all grabs the pawn on
A6 seriously
the man has no fear
his these days am I right I know he
didn't have his breakfast he clearly
just woke up
yeah I mean I would think or maybe a
maybe a late midnight snack there for
for nehal it is late but yeah Bishop
Basics basically saying that Anish
doesn't have a good response to this
like the on the bright side you do
control the CH squares so there is no
Tempo gaining move on the queen
maybe he can actually get away with this
Yeah the more I look at it and I think
the more anishkiri looks at it uh the
more it seems like this is precisely the
best way to prepare castle and King side
so maybe black should play Rook a b in
any way what do you make of that or do
you think and you should maybe try Queen
H4 and queen H3
it's not that easy to play Black here
either a lot of options and hard to
evaluate Queen A7
is his choice
so I guess he's gonna play this very
concretely uh Bishop is going to drop
back to E2 most likely
and then he'll go for his Rook C8 and
Rook V8 plan I feel and just try and eat
everything on the queen side
aha or maybe Rook fb8
and meet your old idea exploiting the
fact that Rogue B1 of course still not
possible
yeah no reason to drive the queen away I
guess in haste yeah I I think at the
very least black is not at risk here you
can always regain material but it's just
a question of what is the best way to
keep applying pressure
and we have extolled uh nihal sarin
thoroughly for his ability to handle
complicated positions with little time
this is a complicated position but it
also could turn into a lost position
pretty quickly but let's see how Anish
Gary handles this situation as he
himself drops down now to 90 seconds he
continues to play Fast your move Rook
FCA chased the queen away
and now the bishop is undefended
so Rook AB8 Jeffrey looks Mighty
tempting since A4 doesn't work due to
Rook takes B5 very important tactic uh
to point it out and if not for A4 then I
guess
I'm looking at a move like Queen A6
right now but it does
I mean worst case black can play the end
game there if they want they can also
even keep queens and just keep keep all
the all the ideas alive
so something like Rook C7 maybe but I
like your idea take the queen go Rook C6
Newhall now down to 25 seconds I don't
think he sees a move I don't see a move
either
you know what makes things even worse is
that after Bishop B2 Rook takes B2 again
you can't Castle
forced yeah I think this this is the
practical way to go you're not going to
survive that position with Queens on the
board having only 20 seconds so this is
his best shot it is of course unpleasant
after the end game
um which we were mentioning yeah and the
same problems persist in the end game
maybe White's gonna have to bank
uh on his a pawn just closed his eyes
and start pushing but Queen takes A6 and
Rook C6 followed by Rook takes B2 just
looks you know I'm foaming at the mouth
just looking at that end game Anish
though investing some time here
any other candidate moves I think he's
considering just keeping Queens on the
board to base I mean just based on
niho's time situation so he wants to
keep the complexity on the board maybe
Queen seven or queen E7 could feature
threats like Rook B6 maybe Rook A8 oh
Rook A8 is a huge threat after Queen C7
and he's exactly and he plays it and
literally traps the queen it forces
white to give away a piece with Queen C6
how does nehal defend against that and
keep his Bishop protected at the same
time right you still can't vacate the
bishop I queen A4 there's Queen B6
there's Queen B6 here oh Queen B6
I guess Bishop D7 but then the bishop is
gonna get caught in the midst of black
spaces that's game over
isn't it yeah he goes I mean
though
uh is there Queen B7
yeah there is Queen B7 that just wins a
piece
doesn't see it though he's down to eight
seconds himself Queen C6
wait a second oh okay Bishop B8 King f8
and now the bishop is gone
so trap but can Neil keep the queen side
intact he's still got chances If he if
he can hold on to all the pawns and this
is where I have seen him pull out the
absolute most unimaginable comebacks but
with three seconds he's dropping a bunch
of his Queen side Pawns
he's still trying he's got the connected
passers Jeffrey it's not totally over
but I love that Bishop on D3 stopping
the pawns dead in extracts ships before
yeah Stop The Rook dead in its tracks
and now bring the king yeah
this should be pretty clean
and he's just decided to create a
password himself
no this is I mean it just hurts me all
that his pawns aren't moving
yeah this looks like Flawless technique
from Niche she's keeping wait a wait a
second oh I'm oh but if Bishop B5 that's
a dagger that's a dagger is it he should
have tried King F5 there maybe hoping
for a pre-move
[Laughter]
he's not gonna design just yet he's
gonna make him work for it
as an Easter I think you just make a
bunch of random moves not to hurt your
position but to get more time in the
clock and that's exactly what he's doing
no this is this has been clinical
execution for Anish he never dropped
down below you know four seconds
but still some work required I mean I
would bring the King around and maybe
even take on F3 at the right moment
right what you don't want to allow is a
trade of Pawns
and suddenly and yeah in that scenario
it would be close uh oh and key six
beautiful technique and King D5 diagonal
opposition shouldering and a win
oh superb stuff well that's exactly what
the doctor ordered for Unleashed
beautiful start here a win with the
black pieces and quite convincing my dad
no totally and he did something there at
the very end that you normally see from
bullet veterans right he took his time a
lot of players kind of overcompensate by
playing too quickly but he built up a
big time advantage and then he took
those last 10 seconds to calculate out
the pawn on game
as you said superb win for Anisha now
he's got the white pieces
gotta keep trying to make that early
push can't take the foot off the gas
pedal now
and I want to mention this A3 Nims
though that Anish is uh opting for here
I believe it's the move that
uh Jordan benforest His compatriot
played against him in white so it's
possible that he's looked at it in depth
and he might
he might uh use this as his main weapon
for for today's match
yeah it's been a lot more popular
recently
uh whereas just a couple of years ago it
was totally dead in the water so always
interesting to see how opening Fashions
change so Jeffrey in these types of
positions white builds up this massive
Pawn Center and he continues expanding
the center the question is can black
chip away at that center and open things
up exploiting a lot of the weaknesses
the white has created as a result
yeah E5 is not a typical move uh in this
position
yeah yeah he's gonna try bolster it with
F4 I I don't recall this line like I've
checked it myself uh for both colors
actually and all right most intuitive to
me is this D6 move which you mentioned
I guess Anish will just continue
developing with Knight F3 is that is his
concept I think so Knight F3 Bishop D3
that actually already threatens a great
gift sacrifice funnily enough
and there is the traditional idea in
such positions of actually attacking the
pawn on C4 and you do that by playing B6
Bishop A6 Knight A5 but Jeffrey with the
pawns driven as far down as they are
that just seems too slow you could very
well walk into a Greek gift uh in just a
couple of moves
oh you really could
yeah I mean right out of the opening
these positions tend to lead to really
interesting imbalances like where white
Devils the C pawns they have two Bishops
and like a sort of
um initiative on the king side which
they try to take advantage of
fantastic choice for a Blitz game as
nehal does opt for B6 Bishop A6 and I
think Here Comes Bishop D3 the
additional benefit Jeffries that you
could then as to use your word bolster
the C4 Pawn with Queen E2 uh if
necessary
but nihal shuts things down with F5 that
was his idea I really love that move
just uh reading all of the Greek gift
ideas for good first and foremost
and
also that Bishop on C1 not exactly
shining so I think concretely Anish has
to
to address some issues
yeah it's I I wouldn't put too much
stock in the evil bar here if black can
get a knight A5 Rook C8
if you lose the C4 Pawn Jeffrey you also
lose your control over D5 and you can
think about a knight getting to D5 that
can escalate really really quickly so
white has to continue demonstrating
active play in the center and on the
king side
is there any case to be made for taking
on passant my intuition says no but
maybe that's what a niche needs to open
up the center well I would I would not
let that Knight see the the light of day
I'm looking at D5 right now and after
Knight A5 I consider D6 but whoa he
launched an attacker with G4 what is
this
a niche tall with G2 G4
and his idea F takes G4 is to meet that
with Knight G5 and probably just leave
that Knight on G5 even in response to H6
holy smokes you're saying he's gonna
Chuck a knight in that position a niche
Geary yes that's exactly what I'm saying
it's move 12 and we've already got
fireworks
I'm trying to calculate it yeah it's
do we have time to show it on the
analysis board yeah we do this could
really heat up in that line let's bring
up an analysis board so you're saying
Jeffrey FG Knight G5 H6 yes I'm claiming
he wants queen takes G4 say let's see
what about HD because I've got Rook of
five at my disposal
and that's a very important resource to
meet Queen H5 with rock F5 let's say I
play FG
is this too slow
amazingly enough it's hard for black to
to find defensive moves like that 98
completely stuck
you can't ever go Knight F6
um
he yeah nice to go for it okay uh ah he
played D5 instead wow counter-attacking
in the center
he probably calculated up to this point
and just didn't see a way to defend but
instead D5 GF is on the board
speaking of fireworks holy smokes What's
Happening Here
this is insane uh I feel like
I was gonna mention this is a totally
legitimate positional idea because if
you can get rid of the light squared
Bishop oh these light squares get really
weak on the king side and in the center
yeah Petrosian certainly smiling at this
for sure what do you
I don't actually like Bishop flag
because for all the reasons you
mentioned like that Bishops would be a
monster and it feels like it's worth
more than the Rook so the move that's
catching Maya is Knight G5 here the
target
and then blackett insists on the
exchange sack but it's far less
effective if the bishop stays alive uh
staying alive he takes on F5
I'm with you Jeffrey I I was very
skeptical about this maybe he wants like
something very concrete like Queen A4
I did not notice that that is a clever
little double attack there but I guess
in this Knight A5 it it just seems like
a superficial one move threat Rook G1
as Anish keeps his eyes trained on the
king side
ig5 on the horizon
so he's gonna keep his King in the
middle that's
that's a very unique way of playing but
I like it
maybe park it on F2 and it was a
compromise move
yeah it it's not actually easy for black
to get his knights in like you want to
plan a night on e4 if you can but
there's simply no access
okay so the position's starting to clear
up a little bit the U-Haul has a pawn
for the exchange black has this very
kind of straightforward idea of bringing
the Knight to E6 and that's a monster
Square
Jeffrey that E6 Square oh
juicy blockade indeed now Anish with
Bishop F2 he's playing to swing the
bishop over to the king side
yep he's still stubbornly trying to
attack down that open G file
but the moment black puts it out on E6 I
mean look at how many functions it has
there you guard on G7 you attack both D4
and F4 not to mention you're blocking
the pawn for good
so
it's very hard for me to evaluate this
position I must say
well it's all that means it's zeros you
know that's basically the golden rule of
evaluating complicated positions
and hey look at what the evil bar is
showing
yeah surprise surprise well
and I I'm surprised also why Neil is
thinking here oh 19 contemplating 96. I
was gonna propose night F6 but that's
actually why Anish played Bishop F2 then
Bishop H4 eliminates the Knight he goes
for the slow roll approach
he was worried clearly about Anish
putting something on G5
yeah I wouldn't know about that
I mean inel shoes I would have brought
the Knight to E6 Pronto without even
thinking but H6 does he want to keep
flexibility maybe he's still got this
Knight D6 in the back of his head
yeah he spent over a minute on the Move
now Knight D2 could be a nasty
possibility
because black now has all sorts of
weaknesses on the king's side instead
Bishop H4 by Geary but what's his
follow-up gonna be because Knight C7 if
it doesn't happen now I was gonna say we
need an intervention if he doesn't play
it here
yeah finally does play also and he's
playing that King F2 move which you
highlighted earlier does he want to
double on the G file
it's hard to say yeah and he goes for it
Queen D2 Rook G1 and then maybe stick a
rook on G6 Bishop F6
is uh looming in the air
so nihal might have to put his King on
H7 just to eliminate these g-file
shenanigans
yeah but even when you double in the G
flow I'm trying to find a way how you
increase
because it's not easy like there's no
way around that 906
yeah I think Anish might have
underestimated how strong King H7 is
defensively Bishop F6 just doesn't work
you take it okay Rook G6 looks
impressive but what's the threat white
might be at a dead end here and black is
unrolling some serious Queen side play
Jeffrey maybe even B5 A5 and B4 you
could really take it slow yeah I don't
see what queen E3 does you could also
try and start penetrating that Rook uh
via the C file which that seems to be
where he's heading precisely what he's
doing he wants to move that Knight out
of the way and Rook C2 is going to be a
pretty devastating threat coupled with
Knight C4
oh
oh yeah yeah
whoa Bishop whoa what is this hang on a
second if I take
well we're about to find out he simply
takes back oh and queen F6 Rook G6 is
his idea oh my that is that is huge and
meanwhile there's Rook G7 so rookie
eight Queen Street instantly hitting the
Knight and as you said Rook G7 here is a
massive threat how does nehal defend
against both oh my God seven seconds and
counting this is just I don't see you
should buy a niche this is unbelievable
one second no he gives up C6 and now
it's basically over I didn't see a
defense either he's gonna try oh no but
this isn't even gonna get it done the
simplest is Rook G6 here but you don't
even need to rush uh
looks great just waiting in maybe Queen
D6 Knight F4
oh
wait that might actually have worked oh
my God that might have worked so Anish
is not taking any chance to just get
that Queen off the board plays Queen D6
and that's probably Worth showing after
the game now Knight H4 ends the game wow
so what a start
he's so sharp I mean I thought niho was
sort of getting somewhere on the queen
side but he slammed that move Bishop F6
which I didn't see coming from a mile
away
and I did I mean there's just so hard to
defend there with no time let's instant
replay that if we could bring up an
analysis board really really quickly I
promise we won't spend long but just to
remind everybody of what Anisha said
Bishop F6 so the actual idea was to meet
Queen F6 with the Rook G6 this is easy
to miss so nihal goes rookie eight now
the queen swings to C3 attacking the
Knight on the other side of the board
apparently Jeffrey the only way to stay
in the game was Bishop C4 and giving up
the queen this way but how do you find
that with no time on the clock once you
get the night up the game is over and
there was another trick to avoid uh if
you had just made a neutral move black
could have moved the Knight away and
been threatening rookie two apparently
White's still winning but the way Fury
converted that was so clean
wow Surgical
absolutely Surgical and the pressure is
suddenly on the hall to to sort of stop
the bleeding here
I mean Anish has come here to play like
maybe he saw
that uh that Neo was a slight favorite
he's
trying to prove them wrong right now
he's trying to prove them wrong he is
proving them wrong
and I like his position again uh in game
three here nihal suddenly with the white
pieces has a lot of things to prove well
wait a second
oh oh yeah anisha's black I was about to
say there are some tactics here like
connected with uh for example Rook one
maybe you can even take on B2 there get
greedy I'm not sure if you do that
Bishop A6 though that is
now that you you point that out I like
like this much more yeah and the issue
is that B3 is never possible when I
Niche speaking of not having had your
breakfast
I would rule this out Jeffrey just
because I don't like giving up the
fiancado bishop in these cases but I
think what Geary's saying is that if
white plays Bishop D4 he can maybe take
on B2 and shut the bishop down with E5
do you think
this makes sense
I mean I know that as a king's Indian
player yourself you're never ever
considering uh tearing my heart out this
yeah but staring my heart out I don't
know maybe he feels like there's not
enough material for white to really
benefit from from the lack of that
defensive Bishop
yeah I mean white isn't left with that
many pieces obviously especially if
another pair of Rooks gets traded okay
Queen C7 hitting the Rook on ba
yeah where is that Rook going
I think it's got to go back home
I don't actually see another Square
you're not going to Rook A8 obviously
you just get trapped there so
yeah it's Gotta Go Rook B1 and now
guessing you take on E1 and develop the
bishop looks very very stable yet again
for for Niche here no totally he's not
getting mated here although I could try
Queen C3 on the board first serious
threat of the game here with Bishop H6
but you could just throw an F6 and he
does
oh and look at me five
the positional Pawn sack F take C5 I
think he wants to take on C5
and play rookie one
and
but even there I mean what exactly are
you playing for I go Rook of fourth for
instance
no you're playing from your back foot
here for sure there's no way black can
be worse he's two pawns up after all
yeah I mean
pawns are ugly here for black but they
are still still Pawns
and if you're Gary I think you're not
playing conservatively I think you're
going for a 3-0 edge here I mean you
can't catch nehal reeling that many
times so this is a chance for a niche to
follow your advice and run it up
as early in the match as possible
oh absolutely you step on the gas here
as a niche um especially
uh considering the start he's he's
feeling it like that Bishop F6 move
already shows me that Anish is in great
form
and yeah now goes Bishop F5 I guess
as white I don't think you trade Bishops
here but on the other hand where where
else how do you avoid it
well you can move the bishop but that
looks Mighty awkward like you could play
Bishop A4 maybe or Bishop B3
nehal does trade on F5 and I was going
to mention G4 is a very weakening move
but you really have to try to restore
the material balance here
yeah you do at the end of the day and
maybe for Anisha oh I was going to
suggest dropping back and then seeking
activity with the queen but this also
works don't don't forget about that
before that's a check I almost forgot
about that yeah but I think a simple
move like Queen D6 should should suffice
aha
yeah and still I contend that black
cannot possibly be worse this is
probably going to be a draw
some way somehow the bonds are going to
liquidate
that would be my best guess as well
although
I'm I'm looking at Queen D6 maybe Queen
e3s is the response and all of a sudden
White's gonna start attacking everywhere
in E7 C5 F4
yeah and the last thing you want is to
give away the E7 Pawn
um and allow long-term play down the
e-file
you know I think at this point Anish has
to bail out if he sees the option to do
so but I don't see a clean way to bail
out here I might even prefer white in
this position what about Rook F3
trying to exchange Rooks tactically
right definitely an option I might but I
might even
ah no Queenie one you got Rook H3 Maybe
yeah Queen D6 he goes for your move
after
a very long 70 second think
and what's his response to Queen E3
that's the big question
can you go Queen D4 and just force a
force a draw a shin game just say for
goodness sake all Rokon games are drawn
exactly 24 Rook C5
hit rookie four I feel like ah no but
then King F2 maybe Rook up so Rook has
three in that case yeah let's bring up
an analysis board really quickly what
we're discussing is Queen D4
Rook takes C5 you can't take the Rook
wean takes E3
F take C3 and now not rookie 4 King F2
but Rook to F3 and this has to be
uh but he's allowed rookie seven in the
game I don't know if if he's showing
ambition or if he just didn't like that
end game
I don't know I feel like he might be
losing the grip here a little bit it
still must be a draw
and maybe it's just a Perpetual Queen D1
and wherever you go black just gives the
corresponding diagonal check
aha yeah I can't really Venture up the
board I was trying to see if I get my
king up to H4 but you've always got
Queen F6 all right wait a minute yeah
you engage four Queen F6 and then Queen
F2 got mated
yeah so this was just a very safe way to
make a draw
a solid result for Anish he keeps the
two point Edge
and another indicator Jeffrey of good
form where he just took over a minute as
long as it took and he just hammered out
that drug he didn't give nehal any
unnecessary chances wait a second whoa
rookie wait a second why did I not think
this was a move yeah it is I I didn't
think so either because you're pitting
yourself
right counter-intuitive maybe called
that draw too soon the game goes on here
oh definitely called that Toronto soon I
think Rook D4 he just wants to drop his
King back to stop Rook D3 and then the
Rook is free to roam about the cabin uh
oh
uh oh
and I feel like that caught Anisha of
guard because he he was taking a casual
sip of water probably expecting the game
to end but
now all of a sudden yeah King G2 there
it is 50 seconds now
and for the first time this match
reneish feeling the heat on the clock
here
yes this is what
I feel like this is the best recipe for
success as niho to to combine
uh pressure on the clock with the board
he does this so effectively in in other
matches that I've seen
he's the best in the business at that 25
seconds for an each maybe King F7 is
what the doctor ordered here just
prevent The Rook infiltration but it's
such a hard move to play he plays it
but he's never get away with this
ah if I play Queen of three again you
probably played the end game down a pawn
Maybe
saying queen or do you just drop the
king away
and there's nothing there yeah
okay so maybe it's still within uh
within the margins here I think it is
and let's not forget black is still up a
pawn so he's got that small cushion as
weak as the queen side pawns are
I don't see a good way for nehal to
throw more kindling onto the fire I'm
looking at a queen B3 move trying to
enter through the queen side and sort of
reconfiguring my setup ah Queen B3 Queen
B7 Shenanigans going on
I think he's gonna do that
it looks like the only attempt but I
have a feeling that even after like King
F6 I don't really have a good follow-up
or maybe King f8 but knocking G7 because
then there's a very nasty check on B7
and the heavy pieces double on the
seventh round he does try it okay oh
okay the problem is if you move the Rook
I'm instantly swapping Queens with Queen
D5 but hold on a sec rookie three rookie
three
oh meeting a check with a check
that does
yeah he plays it King G7 Queen B7 Queen
D7 black still holding on but he's got
10 seconds this is tricky I would want
to keep the queen along the pin but can
you
like Queen B7 King H6 can I do that
yeah then Queen E7 you have Rook F4
oh wow no he's not gonna you're not
gonna take that risk Queen B7 now Queen
B8 perhaps threatening threatening made
in one
oh what a tricky move misdirection and
he's threatening A5 as well I don't
think Anish is surviving this oh man
yeah only five seconds 27 he can take
either Pawn
I would take A5 just for the imbalance
create the outside passer it's not over
but for the first time we're talking
about an objective Edge for white
is that
now see Force I think you start move I
think you just start pushing here though
with A4
yeah you never know when you'll get
another chance to do that
yeah Queen season 3 would be met by C5
uh I don't know where else to put that
Queen which is why I think in general
you always are gonna push but you don't
know where to put the queen that's why
you want to stay flexible oh Queen C3
check now
A5 keep pushing
or this oh he's gonna flag and he gives
up something yeah
wow
what a win for Neil Hall
what an important moment I mean
I called that too soon I feel really bad
like I missed saying it's the rookie
five
and he just found a way to keep the game
going
I mean he was repeating moves listen I'm
pretty sure Anish thought the game was
over you called it he kind of sat back
in his chair and that psychological
effect suddenly you're backing back on
the defensive
I mean that's what nihal does so well he
squeezes out any position like doesn't
matter how Josh it seems
it seemed like Anish was in charge for
most of the first half of that game and
yet
using combined pressure on the clock and
on the board
nihal is now within a point big big win
big win right there
Indian and I love that feature chat
um Magnus like when that was shades of
Magnus where no matter the position you
just you just play you keep the pressure
um
well deserved really well deserved
a little bit of nasty there for nihal
now what do we make of this opening
we have a Roy Lopez a sideline and black
is clearly preparing the move F5
yeah this is one of Neil's pet systems
the funny thing about it is I think he's
the only serious player that plays it
it's a Roy Lopez where the Knight
Ventures to G6 not the most typical
Square
and I think he's actually got a pretty
favorable version I like this F5 idea I
don't see how you stop it as white and
yeah maybe he solved all his problems
here I think he has it's you know
reminiscent of a Philadelphia set up
with these pawns on C6 and D6 but these
pawns are actually kind of nice they're
controlling all of the squares on the
fifth Rank and most importantly they're
completely restricting the mobility of
White's Knight which is now zero
prospects sitting on C3
I think black's slightly better after D5
I mean
but okay I see anisha's concept he's
gonna try and
get control of this diagonal maybe The
Rook on A8 will be tied down to A7 he
could follow this up with with a B4
potentially but watch out H2 might be
hanging yeah because G3 black would just
sack to Bishop
Bishop C5 trying to force the bishop
trade
nihal says no no no
and I'm worried that White's got this
massive pile up on the queen side I'm
worried about the long-term prospects
for White's King
yeah and he's playing really fast in a
position where I sense a lot of danger
there could be a bishop H2
siding which I mentioned again G3 would
trap the bishop but I could sack there I
would already have three Pawns in in a
massive attack
and that's a super instructive sequence
that people can't forget about I think a
lot of people just assume that you can't
take on H2 but that sack on G3
is often so so powerful
and now anisha's thinking but I'm afraid
it could be too late
so Bishop D3 I think you take and then
take on H2 as you indicated
and then after G3 you take it
at the very least you're probably
getting a fourth Pawn in that line I
don't think you have
Checkmate per se but you're just
intuitively sacked the bishop in and go
and this is very much nihal style he
likes these long-term sacrifices
you know we saw
The Exchange sack
in the first game it didn't quite work
out but this is very much up his alley
yeah I'm trying to think if Anish has
another response in mind activist D3 CD
Bishop H2
does he want because you can also just
ignore it with with a move like Rook E1
and play for compensation
aha just play for the E file basically
and the dark squares on the queen side
yeah but
I I mean I have trouble really buying
into the composition it is a is an
important age Pawn after all like uh if
you give that up down the roadblocks
Queen could could swing around queen of
seven
so yeah
to take nehal side here I I think he has
to go down that path because if you
don't take on H2 you give light a
respite you give white a chance to play
G3 and suddenly you know white only
needs a couple moves right G3 Rook A1
and suddenly the the flame of Black's
initiative is extinguished so I think
niho doing the right thing to take a
deep think here and he can afford to do
that it's a five minute time control
yeah clearly calculating very critical
moment I think Bishop Ford is the other
move but yeah he does he does
immediately go for this that's why I
didn't put this on the analysis board I
had a pretty good feeling this would
happen on the board
and what is white supposed to do now
Queen D2 but then rookie five
Queen H2 and you just want to grab on it
on F3 exactly I think I just
I was also thinking about Queen G4 there
hold on Queen G4 might be huge
let's pull up an analysis board as Anish
contemplates his next move Queen D2 is
what we're discussing
here right Network H5 so Queen H2 and
you're saying Queen G4
quiet but deadly
how do you deal I mean why is this not
actually winning
why is this not just winning apparently
Queen G2 oh this is your life Queen H5
Queen H2 wow but we might see this on
the board I think we're gonna see this
and we are and rookie five has been
played as of course was Queen D2
let's go back to the live board
and this is so hard to defend from a
practical standpoint he goes Bishop G1
huh
which I didn't see that's a clever
clever defensive research there bringing
this bishop back
and now
as Neil you have time to double the
Rooks not really because Bishop H2 and
like Queen G2 are coming
yeah it's not all you know beaches and
cherries here for black give white a
couple moves he consolidates you don't
want a queen trade if you're black even
if you can get
you know three pawns for the piece which
you have right I think an end game will
be seriously problematic for black given
the dark Square weaknesses on the queen
side
and the inability to move the Rook from
A8
yeah in any end game those Queen side
pawns are going to be Ultra Soft for
black white can pick them off like like
cherries and nice
but I mean meanwhile I was gonna say how
else do you
you like make an idea here for black I'm
trying to form things but nothing seems
to work
I agree I think you have to slow roll it
what she's doing Bishop H2 of course the
idea is Queen H3 you don't lose the Rook
no he goes Rook H5
okay
and now I get something like Queen G2 he
wants to go for your old idea just take
on D3 and say hey I've got four pawns
for the piece for goodness sake
that is true yeah right now I'm do I
have like Queen G no no no I was trying
Queen G2 Queen G3 Queen F3 just to force
the Queens off but you would have rookie
two at the end of the line
aha in the night defense
the f8 square
exactly yeah
there's no rookie one either your
tactics connected with Rook H2 he goes
Knight back to C3 so Anish still in
defensive mode
which makes sense he's stopping
various rookie 2 related ideas
yes controlling E2 is certainly
important
the ball back court yeah at some point
black might want to throw in like an H6
not sure if you do it now but just long
term I'm worried about potential back
rink ideas coming in for white oh
totally no it's a big problem
especially when yeah you're talking
about like a rook for me moving
I was thinking about the move 95 but
that opens up a major can of worms in
the back rank it might allow Queen F2
exactly
so maybe this is the time for H6 just
put it in
especially given your time situation
30 seconds now for nihal he's feeling
the heat again
yeah it's real reversal from from last
game he ultimately does agree with us
it's a good thing pat on the back
now it's important that Rook G1 there's
this queen F3 check move and you
shouldn't rule out sacrifices on H2
White's not out of the woods on the king
side
I love Rook of two though preparing Rook
G1 I think
indeed so maybe time to bring the Knight
into the attack yeah now that you don't
have the back rink problems to worry
about I think oh but 95 rookie one could
that pin be an issue
oh you can't move the Knight give up E8
with check we're about to find out
rookie one
that is a nasty move to face
with your left not even yeah you you
can't even vacate the pin easily you
don't want to play a move like Rook
shade that looks very sad maybe King H7
wow that is deep that is deep I think
the niche is gonna play rookie one
though because otherwise
I mean there are too many threats here
with 93-92 fortnite F3
yeah this could absolutely go either way
another problem for white is that Queen
F4 is never an issue because if a rook
takes H2 it's actually hard to find a
good anchored spot for the queen
and D3 is also hanging
rookie one okay take on D3 yeah I was
not sure how to evaluate this end game I
mean
no whoa Queen H3 so all the threats
still alive you can always go back you
can divert to this rookie one you can
also Queen E2 I'm noticing
you have to stop Knight F3 Knight G4 is
the secondary threat you called it
and there's that rookie six move
threatening
not sure exactly what I guess Knight
taking Knight three is a threat Knight
D3 Knight D3 is a big threat
okay so Queen F1 comes to mind
but then still Knight takes people still
no problem
Rook f8 check though oh Rook Cafe Rook
G7 would be me oh my God what a crazy
idea we'll have to show this one way or
the other he goes D4
Knight D3 what what is the response five
things for Neo has gone oh rook f8 and
Rook up seven
oh my God kidding me oh no
he's fine
no but now
wow this is unbelievable and he wins the
second piece
dude anisha's form is killer right now
that is so sharp how did he find out
that with only 10 seconds
no that was crazy before we go on a
break and there will be a halftime break
we have to pull that up and postmortem
that for those who had a hard time
following I had a hard time following
first of all Jeffrey Rook F7 look at
this move the idea is not Perpetual it's
flat out Checkmate it's flat out
checkmate
beautiful name pattern that everyone
should familiarize themselves with and
Rook G5 was the only move but here came
Rook G5 and Rook F3 another inner meso
counter-attacking on the queen
everything hanging here for black no
defense everything is on perfect spots
Rook takes H3 this it's crucial that
this is check otherwise Knight F2 would
be a fork and white of course picks up
the second minor piece unbelievable
handling of the complex position for
Anish giri he is up three to one but as
we look at the score Jeffrey the good
news for Anish I mean it's only a two
point lead it feels like Anisha has been
totally dominating but there's an
eternity left and uh you know we all had
a nice win there as well
if there's one thing I know about nehal
is he never ever goes away I feel like
he always strikes back I recall on the
GCC match he trailed on multiple
occasions but just always had the
answers so I'm expecting
him to I mean exchange blowford blow
with the niche and we'll see exactly
what he has in mind right after the
break indeed we will we're gonna have 45
more minutes of five plus one action
this match is already living up to the
expectations we'll give the players a
breather we'll take one ourselves and we
will be back with more speed Chess
Championship on the other side of this
short break
chess kit is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
the kids it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
50 000 chest bustles and a whole library
of entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids
chess kit is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the speed Chess
Championship
Grandmaster nihal sarin Grandmaster
Anish giri duking it out in an
incredible SCC match chopping it up for
you today Jim Daniel nerdinsky and GM
Jeffrey Zhang Jeffrey those 45 minutes
felt like three seconds
oh man it was amazing it was just
incredible display by both players
especially Anish though uh over the
break I was thinking just how epic that
combination was it was even
more unbelievable is the fact that I
think he had to find that entire
combination
to not be worse like he would have been
on the ropes if not for all this Rook of
Fate Rook of seven and Rook of three at
the very end so just
insane tactical Vision by Anish
especially under pressure and I I want
to see if he keeps it up
yeah this SCC has been all about defying
expectations I mean we had Fabiano
caruana right we talk oh he's not a good
bullet player levonne aronian hasn't
played any Bullet at all and now
anishagiri he's not going to be able to
handle it in time scrambles guess what
none of those narratives were true but
45 more minutes of five plus one action
nihal has the white pieces and once
again very important for him to deliver
here and stop this match from getting
out of control you lose two more games
boom you know it's a four-point match
and now we see a grundfloat which I know
Anish has essayed in the past but his
normal repertoire against D4 exists of
nimso so this could have caught niho
slightly off guard
yeah and he kind of responds to the the
quiet setup the bishop on D2
and I've seen people play this before D
takes C5 grabs a pawn
but
Jeffrey this is supposed to be fine for
black I wonder what nehal is going to
bring to the table here this looks
I'm skeptical about his setup
yeah it's actually it's this subtle
um opening I believe it was played by
Alexi drev and I had the same impression
when I was playing over the board like
what is this is nothing just make an
easy drawing go home but it turns out
that white clings onto that D5 Pawn
it's not necessarily easy for black to
to prove full equality without knowing
what you're doing here
oh for sure no that makes sense 8684 of
course the stop B5 so does black want to
try B6 and Bishop B7 here
I mean maybe that weakens the C6 square
a little too much I think yeah the
problem with B6 might be white could go
like Queen E2 delaying castles just to
threaten E4 that might be an idea
no I totally agree that's on but I love
anisha's last move Bishop F5
clearly trying to prepare Knight fe4 and
that's very much in the spirit of the
grundfold playing in the center and
bringing all of his pieces into the game
yeah I still feel like there are games
in this line it was it's a blast from
the past actually this line used to
be pretty topical I want to say back in
like 2016. and it is
I believe it it's either Knight C4 here
or there's like a bishop G4 at some
point you're right on the money I'm
looking at opening Explorer there are
still games in this position and more
than one of them and even Rook fd1 has
been played
now I see that Bishop G4 was played in
all three games
to have reached this position is Anish
going to deviate
clearly both players I think are out of
book at this point but maybe not uh you
never know you really never know yeah
you're just trying to recall things
now Bishop G4 Jeffrey I think is a nasty
little move because it creates the
positional threat of Bishop takes F3
let's not forget the bishop on C4 is
under Fire
yeah white has to be careful he's got a
lot of hanging pieces I could also
Envision like that Bishop on G7
uh seeing the light of day and being a
monster so
yeah it's uh not wait a second though
Knight G4 I have not seen
yeah that is quite the move and he's
trying to force the exchange on e4 and
then he's saying hey my Bishop is going
to be a beast in that position
I don't know 94 and Bishop C3 comes to
mind
I guess in that case you'd be left with
a weak weakness on seat three after
after the trades
and other weaknesses
I'm looking at so 94 looks correct and
then where do you move the bishop maybe
it's a B4 to attack on E7 makes sense
uh-huh and you're also opening up
contact between the rook and the D5 pawn
and
allowing the possibility of D6
I go Queen C7
oh
setting up nasty attacks all over C4 and
on H2 wow that is a nice idea
thorny and nihal isn't rushing to take
on e4 is there any other Canada moves no
he takes on e4 he was thinking about his
next move
and Knight F3 to G5 you called it he
moves his Knight
so yeah now what is black supposed to do
now
two pieces are hanging Bishop F5 is the
most obvious to protect both but then
exactly then like E4 and you slowly push
push black back and might add you it's
it's still a pawn down Ascent a Central
Pawn so
there's something to prove here for a
niche
yeah and you can Feast your eyes on the
smarter Chess Live predictions on the
lower right hand side of your screen I
always love seeing the swings of that
graph
and right now Anish 61 favor to win but
obviously way too early to tell we have
an eternity still left
and Jeffrey I think E4 his idea is Queen
C7
still
threatening Checkmate on H1
that is a very powerful idea but you
know what I'm looking at like a D6 in
that position
bc7 D6
and if Queen takes D6 then you can well
then now defense C4 uh is no longer
hanging so I think I go G3 also I have
discoveries with the bishop F7 is a
target
D6 is a great move and it might be the
only one and he plays it
beautiful spot
and now here's the second point if you
take on C4 I'll take and then I take on
E7 then I take on F5 and at some point
I'll slam down to move Rook d8
let's bring open analysis board to show
that's a very instructive line you're
saying Queen C4 there's the very
important intermediate move d e that
hits the Rook
and the nasty possibility of The Rook
appearing on d8 makes this such a nasty
position to defend guess what it's on
the board he's gone for it and this
position is on the board great call
yeah we're going right down the rabbit
hole if he takes on E7 the question
which I have
do I have a good fall up there
oh my God there's some crazy lines where
if blackley's h60 and tries to throw
that in I'm thinking about the bishop
moving away sacking the Knight and going
Rook d8 probably too speculative
oh my to your point Jeffrey Rook takes
C7 of course has to be assessed first
because if that move works out white
could end up being worse here
in the end
well hang on a second white is currently
up two pawns so I don't think oh am i
counting it right yeah yeah it's an
optical illusion but it is actually
coupons here no that changes a
lot that changes a lot I thought Rook
takes C7 restores the material balance
but it doesn't
right but I think you still gotta play
it like he might
see if he can throw in the move H6 it
looks so speculative though
yeah H6 and it might not even be the
greatest thing in the world to chase the
Knight away from F3 why could just say
hey okay fine I'm just gonna stabilize
my material advantage Bishop to D4
is the approach taken by Gary as he
hunts for activity as much activity as
possible to compensate for his lack of
Pawns right he cuts off the default from
The Rook Sonoma Rook d8 ideas and I
guess he's saying that E7 is a dead duck
anyway so he can pick that up at his
convenience
I think a wild Eric Rosen is going to
appear you mentioned the word duck
you fled your Sheriff duck chess haven't
you I have played against Eric himself
and let me just say that
it was uh it was a humbling experience
for me it wasn't exactly a jam against
uh
and or is he an FM or iron But whichever
he is in Duchess it was a different
story
he fell for some quaktics
um I had a similar experience or
whatever I think Toronto
yeah it was more of not seeing quaktics
like I tried to stack for an initiative
but he always used that duck just to
block all of my ideas it's one of the
most annoying things I've ever faced and
right now Nee Hall is facing some
annoying threats on the board how does
he defend the pawn on F2 because a move
like Knight E4 is very loose that walks
into Rook take C7
so I guess Bishop E1 comes to mind
to open up the D file but that seems
passive as well Jeffrey this one is
pretty double-edged
right this was a nice fine but my knees
we see three so what is oh does he want
Bishop C through Rook d a
oh my gosh
and then I guess that forces
roxier no that's out of the question I
think
what if it takes F2 check and then drop
back to H6 or something oh
excellent idea excellent idea because
then you'd set up Night Forks
and you could do the same thing by the
way Bishop B6 and then Knight E3 check
is a massive threat and you're stopping
Rook d8
most importantly and you've also got
rookie 7 and Knight H2 on tap as well
apparently not the best move but neither
was nihal's response he allows 93 check
but obviously GF is a huge map threat I
like just I think you can go HG oh no he
finds Rook of four oh my God and Jeffrey
there's like Knight takes H2 check and
rookie seven you're just collecting all
the pawns with check and White's King is
caught on the crossfire Knight F2 is now
a massive threat and black is in charge
rookie one only moves to to avoids
and 93 but the time Advantage I mean
yeah the time situation is very
favorable for niho that's a big that's
an important thing I feel like White's
favorite to win this game given the time
situation exactly yeah so do you jump 96
you can also throw in like an A5 at any
moment five very much a knee-haul move I
think to play A5 first
and maybe even G3 can be considered
you caught it he plays it and now where
do you even put the Rook
and you're starting to crumble A5 Bishop
A7 still holding on is Anish giri
uh-huh I guess it's all under control
for the moment
maybe a move like rookie two just kind
of try to keep the tension double your
Rooks
black can always go
yeah yeah I don't see another idea other
than doubling
goes for a face seven
wow the waney hall has managed to
position his pieces here controlling all
of the key infiltration squares but he's
got one second 96. this move allows him
nice he said oh my God and there's H4
made at the end oh my God
hey
rookie seven it's me there's gonna be H4
checkmate oh
oh what a mate
we have been spoiled so far in this
match there have been so many brilliant
tactics shown we're only
what is this like six games in or five
games in but I mean it's it's been a
fascinating display and another one
another amazing illustration another Gem
and nihal's wins have been so gritty but
it took him a millisecond to find 96 and
Jeffrey we kind of called it earlier
it's really only a matter of time when
you've got two seconds against nehal in
a complicated position he is going to
trick you one way or the other might
take him five moves might take him 15
and it's going to happen that was a
beautiful mating combination in the end
game
incredible stuff we're witnessing so far
okay and we have a Karo Khan
a little bit of a toned down opening
after that display of fireworks
yeah I thought creation I was thinking
niho might actually go back to the e45
because I I love this position with that
unorthodox setup 97 8g6 but as I said
before the match he does like to mix mix
things up
yep and I've seen him play the Karo Khan
pretty consistently he also likes the
French
so okay so Knight H6 very typical
developing Square correct me if I'm
wrong Jeffrey I'm not a big specialist
in this line but I've seen the knight
jump into F5 kind of like in the French
I mean there's a lot of shared ideas
with the advanced French I feel like F6
might be his idea sometimes the Knight
Retreats itself to F7
finds a home there you fight for this
very important E5
and the position is going to get very
sharp especially if we have a trade on
F6 and the Center opens up you sometimes
see black castling Queen side here
now I was even considering taking with
the pawn
but maybe it would have been too much
Queen takes F6 he just wants to go
Knight F7 Bishop D6 and finish his
development
yeah Knight B3 a niche Paving
open the diagonal for his bishop and
deploying it to E3 but again I think
nihal has handily solved all of his
opening problems
yeah I love this and he's gonna generate
an initiative once again sooner or later
with this E5 move which you're
highlighting
and as white what where exactly are you
going to be playing
yeah what's your night doing what's your
Bishop doing
and you said what are you doing against
the positional threat of E5
and they're actually going to get a
similar structure Jeffrey oddly enough
to that E4 E5 game
like they might get an identical Pawn
structure with this Pawn chain in the
center
yeah Anish
got the better of him like he did win
that game but that was dangerous like I
thought I would have been shaking in my
boots uh as a niche he entered it very
well I'm not sure if he can get away
with it twice in a row though
I think anisha's slippers and a guy
I don't know
just a guess
so I think he's ready for E5 I know Rook
A1 is
is always useful but I still see nothing
wrong with just an E5 break here
yeah you don't want to overcook it
because and I think that might be what
he's doing he throws in H6 does it cover
G5 Square he basically says there's no
hurry
but does this give Anish a chance to
prepare himself better for E5 and if so
how
yeah I would consider I was going to say
I was considering a maneuver like Knight
C1 put get the knight in the center but
gonna try Queen D1 not sure
exactly what
what the concept is but perhaps just
another useful waiting move anticipating
uh E5
yeah maybe just you know moving the
queen out of the the line of fire of a
potential Knight that appears on E5
taking the Stick of Knight C4 near Hall
continues to prepare it and prepare it
and I think he's gonna go Rook a to E8
now yeah this one I quite like because I
don't see any disadvantage to playing B6
so I like that he's brought his final
piece into the game
full Army now participating and
uh if I mean oh the Knight H2 is nice
Knight H2 I think he wants
does he I was gonna say maybe he had a
Bishop G4 but yeah I thought Bishop G4
too but he goes Knight G4 now the queen
kind of sinks its teeth into this very
nice Square on H4 it's actually very
safe there for the time being
okay trade on E5
it feels like all the black pieces are
just lurking around White's King
yeah this is starting to heat up
seriously and that I think is the
drawback of B6 you've got this very
tender Pawn on C6 now so you can't as
easily move the Knight away from E5 and
if you lose that pawn and by the way
Jeffrey Knight takes C6 is a threat
right it is right now which I just
realized yeah and the funny thing is I
was going to just move like king h8 or
King H7 you might still have Knights oh
because you're forking the two miners
maybe Rook F6 there at the end but I
agree it gets super messy
yeah that is quite amusing and how else
do you take care of the issue yeah like
how do you defend against this very
obvious threat
oh my gosh
I don't see it off the top of my head
yeah I mean
I'm looking at Bishop E4 but that feels
loose it can always be kicked oh my God
and you can maybe still play Knight
takes C6 and follow up with the slow
move F3 I mean this is unbelievable
and obviously Bishop F7 walks into
Knight F5 that's 1-0
for the blender such things
um
is there no no there's there's really
not I'm trying to now I'm trying to
investigate like King
H7 Knight c696 Queen D5
I'm trying to investigate that because
otherwise you don't want to make a
move like like Bishop before really fast
if we could bring him an analysis board
as snehal continues to ponder well
actually just as I said that of course
he waited for me to say that and then
played the move Bishop E4 I did play it
yeah so I was just going to point out
real fast that in this position there's
this idea of going Rook to F6 but after
takes takes you can't take on C6 but you
can play the simple move Rook D1 and
you're basically just skewering all of
Black's minor pieces so maybe nihal
calculated this decided that it was out
of the question and opted for your
initial suggestion Bishop E4
and here I was saying that you can still
take on C6 and play F3 is there any
Merit to that
it feels too weakening though on the
diagonals right like you're weakening
the squares there around the king
so
I just feel intuitively I would go for
something else
simplify
does he have F no it's still F4 Knight
G6
and there's this queen G3
idea that could come knocking if you
play F3 at the wrong moment
oh my I mean by the way also Queen F4
Queen G3
oh absolutely yeah this could get scary
I don't like Knight takes E5 I feel like
that
right he might have needed that Knight
too to
I mean engage in in the defense of
White's King so now
I feel like he wanted to follow it up
with F4 but he realized that would just
be too weakening like all these Queen G3
Knight G6 oh he plays F3 but what do you
do after Queen G3 I assume Bishop too
you have to
oh my god there are some crazy tactics
there
but there might be something
my juices are flowing like Nike whoa
Knight G4 takes Queen G3 wait wait look
at Knight G4 here oh my God Knight G4
first
what a move okay analysis board please
Knight G4 but hang on AG yeah so this is
mate just to show that real fast FG
what is this so what if you start with
Bishop takes G2
oh my God that is lethal I mean you
called the main idea this is mate
holy smokes here Queen G3 and queen H2
and he's locking in he smells something
he does but will he see Knight G4 and he
does
like this match you could not have asked
for more tactics to start no it's crazy
how many combinations we've had from
both players and our Niche leaning in
he's like WTF is this
oh it's over man iq4 ends the game just
part one this is part one like it's easy
to get tempted with Queen G3 I was
totally on Queen G3 but totally see if
the bishop F3 holds on
yeah does he see that Bishop takes G2
idea I feel like he probably moved it
there's your answer
exactly
that was a statement move and the way he
delivered it was a statement move and
White's King side collapses
that is sick
I guess you can try Knight F5 maybe just
to muddy the waters but nehal has way
too much time on his clock for any of
that to work right just Queen H3 there
he's gonna try to remove it relief
pressure on that foot but I mean another
Rook just shows up
I'd have five Rook F5 and queen G3
is how the game might end
lights out there's also Queen H3 I'm not
sure which you would
which is cleaner I mean oh I I it's hard
to argue with the one you suggested
yeah because it just feels like there's
so many made threats there Neil is going
to double check it
and without further ado
he ends the game unbelievable
Bishop F2 Queen H2 mate
oh this really is a heavyweight match
and just like that he ties it
incredible the match is tied two wins in
a row and not just any wins two wins an
amazing Style by nihal sarin
and just like that the lead has been
erased just like that
and I think Anish wants to make an
adjustment like no he's not gonna get
into he's not gonna allow neon to get
his attack going and immediately playing
something very quiet
see some symmetrical structure here just
calm things down
well the first couple games were
worrisome for nehal but ever since he's
been able to steer the game in the right
kind of Direction he has displayed some
incredible form both players are firing
on all cylinders
okay so they're repeating a line Jeffrey
that they had a couple of times in their
cgc match they had these types of
positions pretty frequently
and nehal is a big fan of these kind of
symmetrical
grinded out Knight F3 type positions
let's see what he manages to make out of
this
yeah if I recall correctly wasn't nehal
the one on the white side of those games
yeah yeah he was
so certainly well versed but I like this
plan by Niche and maybe Neil's copying
him as well with this Rook C2 met by
Rook C7 or is well I guess maybe
anisha's copying niho because I was the
first one to play Rex C2 oh that is true
that is what I meant to say yeah but
okay slightly slightly uh slight
deviation here with Queen EA instead
yeah Queen B8 I think clearly he's
trying to dial up some pressure on the C
file
okay we have a trade
what's going on here Rook takes C5 and
maybe Rook D1 hits that loose Knight on
D7
right it would I guessing Anish would
just respond with like a knight df6
um
not a whole lot
to say maybe I'm looking at a B4 I'm
looking at a B4 and you expand on the
queen side right now
yeah and I I second you that I don't
really see where White's Advantage is
going to come from here it feels like
white is a small initiative White's kind
of calling the shots
but that might be a product of the fact
that White's creating more one move
threats that doesn't have anything to do
with the objective evaluation
right it is easy to get um sort of
misguided when you're making on the
threads feels like you're dictating but
black just responds and they're gonna
hit back at some point
so I feel like he's got to generate
something in order to
to really say that uh he can try with
white
you can try to to dial up some
positional pressure on the C6 Square you
could play B4 yeah Catalan style Knight
D4 and then B5 later but that's really
playing for the kind of long-term ideas
and look at the clock anisha's only
spent 19 seconds
he's up a whole two minutes Niha has to
be careful
right you also have to be careful of
some like Knight F2 not necessarily in
the current position but there could be
like a knight F2 with a knight E4 if
you're not careful you can just remove
I mean you just play a careless move or
two no that's a great point if you
you know remove too many Defenders and
involve yourself too much on the queen
side that could strike at a very
inopportune moment
right so doubles they'll keep it slow
here
maybe B4 is his idea because otherwise I
don't really see it
no definitely I think he's trying to
play on the queen side and for Anish
he's got to figure out where to put this
Rook Rook d8 makes sense
but if you're anticipating before then
so does Rook F to C8 I think that's a
big decision potentially
yes Rook of seed I think I would still
meet it with B4
yep
and if you beat white to the punch I
think that creates too many weaknesses
you don't want to go B5
yes okay he's gonna play it but after B4
where is this Rook going
oh maybe one I think he wants Rook F5
uh-huh
and you called it pressuring the F2 Pawn
yeah because then you could never you
never move the Knight and F3 there might
be some juicy tactics coming again like
imagine a knight F2 Bishop 394 and Rook
F3
potentially oh you could uncork like a
million of those sacrifices in a row
for sure or maybe Knight F2 Queen H2 I
mean
wow the pieces are just stuck on the
queen side that's the danger in any
position and I think U-Haul senses that
he sensed it yes it drops it back good
good sense of okay maybe this this will
get a little bit annoying and I don't
have a lot of time on my clock so let's
just bail out
says knee Hall
exactly and as a niche I think
you know you've lost the last two games
it makes sense to sort of play it safe
here and just swap everything
totally yeah I wouldn't get too enamored
with your time Advantage here this is an
easy position for white to handle
I mean maybe a Anish could make some
token attempts in that resulting end
game but
I don't see any Hall losing a position
this simple
no I don't see it either it's just Rock
Solid
does he want to make a move to at least
try and keep the tension yeah I was
about to say queen D6
so afterwards C5
is he gonna try to keep a pair of Rooks
on the board or just
just fight for the sea fog here with
Rook C4 we're about to find out now he's
just gonna fight for the C file
and again black is symbolically better
here because of the better placement of
his Knight and the bishop and why it has
to be a little bit careful Jeffrey I
could see this getting a little bit out
of hand if there's a knight that lands
on C3 at the wrong moment exactly so
nihal has to be on his toes here
yeah I like
that Anisha is still keeping chances and
I assume that he's going to take with
the night no he takes with the bishop
which slightly surprises me
yeah maybe he was worried about Rook D
Wallen and he wants to preserve the
option of Rook C2
not entirely sure but nihal could take
on C5 at this point I would imagine yeah
I feel like more we're even 95 with
Bishop C4 no he goes to go through
yeah
and Bishop F3 I think is his follow-up
just to totally liquidate the situation
yeah just I mean if you're forcing a
draw then you might as well force a draw
yeah take no chances
and as a niche he's still I feel like
he's still trying he's got he's got this
minute and change ahead on the clock and
he really uses the question
yeah and I feel like super GMS are so
good just no matter who you're talking
about Wesley anise shikaru I mean
obviously Hikaru at creating chances in
these types of positions but nihal is
way too solid he's got too few
weaknesses he's got no weaknesses
I don't see this working out for Anish
yeah Anish might be deciding
whether to force a trade of Queens with
Queen C2 no it goes to H5 oh spicy
trying to force I do balance yeah I do
agree with him that 94 94 would most
certainly be in Black's Advantage you
plant the Knight on C3 in that case
so
for white how do you proceed this you go
hf3 anyway or the problem there is the
blackened maybe take and replace the
bishop with the Knight
and when you think about those Queen
side pawns they could get really weak
even in the event of a night end game so
you all clears out some space for
himself with B4
that's right yeah I like about maybe a
D4 Square for the queen
okay trade
yeah
now
white wants to bring his King in and
then he'll be completely safe there
yep you think about it F3 or you don't
even need F3 you can just go King F1
King E2 straight away
and nihal accompanying his move with a
draw for
what do you think I think you I think
Anish will accept it because there's
really not much
just not much you can do here as black
right you're absolutely right and he
does and that's a totally fair decision
no need to just play
you know for the sake of playing when
you know you're not going to win
yeah it doesn't matter
if you had a whatever it was like 30
seconds niho was was never going to lose
that
okay so the match is tied three and a
half a piece we've got
12 minutes and change left on the match
clock this might be the last game but
probably we'll have time for one more
after this one
and a queen's yes Gambit declined with
kind of a Carl's Bad setup here I've
seen this line so many times recently
yeah it is
slightly unusual that black played in
early age six
is I suppose they normally develop
either their Knight or Bishop but
it is I mean it is always a useful move
yeah and they're playing it earlier and
earlier White's playing H4 on move two
they'll be playing on a move one just
get it out of the way
yeah
so uh okay we see a trade of Bishops
looks
looks like things are calming down from
all the yeah
they've had their share I feel like
we're gonna get another explosion
Jeffrey as they move into the three
minute time control if this is how crazy
things got in the longest time control
imagine what we're gonna see when we
actually get down to the Blitz and
bullet
man I can't wait but here why does this
idea of F34 he can launch it immediately
when black is yet to Castle
I guess maybe Knight H5 is in the mix
uh-huh as well
not that that's a deal breaker
necessarily but if you play E4 without
the dark squid Bishop
obviously the center can get a little
bit loose true
yeah he has to evaluate the consequences
of that I mean I'm okay yeah
now that doesn't preclude F3 does it you
can still play F3 you're not too worried
about the hole on G3
mm-hmm yeah expect him to drop back with
the bishop at some point maybe now
and then as you said you could think
about F34 oh buddy yeah he says why not
right away
why not indeed I like an issu's position
I mean if he can squeeze this through
especially if you go E4 E5
we've both I'm sure seeing our share of
games where black just gets steamrolled
so quickly on the king side
and a common response to F3 is the move
C5 a Counter-Strike in the center
but you would be left with an isolated
Pawn I don't know if you can get away
with that
yeah it's hard to evaluate and with the
Rook sitting pretty on D1
that was a very prescient thing for
Anish to do to put his Rook there in
preparation for C5 you also sometimes
see black playing B5 trying to engineer
some Pawn play on The Queen side but
that does seem a little bit slow here
but maybe that's the way to go I don't
know
yeah sorry I lost you oppression
Mr Stanford here
apologies yeah it does play it though
and it was pressing to put the Rook on
D1 now
he doesn't take automatically now he
does
and I guess Queen F5
and I suppose he's even willing to give
up the Deep pod but in exchange he could
get counter play
um by means of like this weakness on E3
maybe the weakness of B2 I'm expecting
96.
uh-huh
yeah that's a good move
and you're absolutely right in these
types of positions you often see white
keeping upon alive in order to keep the
center relatively close then give
yourself the D4 Square for your minor
pieces so Bishop E5 is not out of the
question here at all
and he's played it
yeah great call if you go Knight D7 I
guess Bishop G3 and then white would now
be ready to just munch on D5
yeah if you can take with a knight and
that Knight is uncontested that's going
to be a problem no black is worse here
yeah I understand it's clearly worse
if I go Queen B6 you simply take on F6
take on D5 and probably got like Rook B1
at the end
that's a nice line
okay that's kind of out of the question
as well
so are you left with kind of a passive
defensive move like 96 to C7 that
actually might be what you end up you
might really have to but that was the
right sound effect to make
at least there is always this kind of
play on E3 though so you for sure you
maybe threatened like a to fire
Bishop D6 and you try to say all right I
have I have the e-file for my Rook
yeah yeah I got some stuff going my way
and the Silver Lining is that even if
you lose D5 that doesn't end the game so
nihal's gonna have his chances here I
think provided ID eventually makes a
move
yeah don't want to slip into uh too long
of a think here
what else
I mean he's probably evaluating all the
like the queen B6 the end game can he
hold that
it's hard it really is hard to play Move
Like 97 so honestly oh definitely it's
like your last resort it's it's what you
play if you truly aren't finding
anything
uh more active than that he's down to a
minute 45 he goes through the other
night Knight D7 but what's his father to
do yeah I uh
what does he wants here go back to F6
and just say hey I'm gonna give up that
pawn go Queen B6 at the end
uh maybe yeah that is
it's not the easiest double attack to
deal with for white
no it's not
and if you have to go Queen back to B3
there at the end I think black's got
pretty solid defensive chances in that
end game
with all these weak fonts
hmm I wonder if you play a preparatory
move like Bishop 2 as a niche
very Soviet Schoolboy type of move I
like it
yeah just kind of nursing this weakness
as much as possible he can't resist he
takes it
Anish likes his pawns but now what
I don't think he's answered that
question either he's like I'll take
first think later
and I certainly don't like
something fell off to me though
I don't know about Rook ACA that might
have been a little bit slow that gives
the Knight a chance to jump into D5
uh-huh and perhaps follow up with E4 no
question that White's playing for two
results here for the time being
yeah I think you jump on this chance to
activate the night
definitely although maybe bishop F6 oh
Bishop F6 94. you've got a fork on D6
lovely little tactic there
misdirection I'm going to D5 no just
kidding I'm going to D6
that's yeah magician's fine moment there
well
I why the hesitancy though yeah I think
Knight C3 has to be the right move
and it's played
and it hurts black that it's actually
not easy to attack B3 if you go Knight
C5
well why can't even play B4 and drive
the pawn up to B5
you might actually be asking for it
there
okay Bishop F6 and here we go
he just goes back to E7 okay but now
don't I have like uh ah D6 there
is F5 I was trying to pave the way for
my knight to land on D6
I feel like a niche might opt for a slow
move like Rook to D2
but then black will play F5
and he might play it anyway
this V5 just to control that diagonal no
more Bishop F6 for you
nice fantastic move fantastic defensive
move by nehal exploiting the undefended
nature of the bishop on E5 he might be
holding this actually he might be
holding this
yeah you absolutely can't trade that
would give black a Tempo gain both
bishop and E Pawn would hang
but meanwhile B3 is hanging
you don't want to allow Knight 64
doubling the pawn so there aren't a lot
of options here no and I'll just show
this quickly if we bring up an analysis
board if you take it and go Bishop D4
and say hey I'm up a pawn again it's all
about piece activity at the end I think
black has rookie three drawing the game
oh my God it's on the board rookie 3 has
just been played they don't call you
oh man that was a good moment a
knee-halt zero hesitation zero
and we're gonna get a draw here we might
get another game
well hang on a second how do you do you
force like do you play Rook C1 or yeah
how do you draw with white yeah yeah how
do you hold this as black if if I take
on B3 and I block your d-pawn
there's some pressure you know run my
pawns up B5 A5 A4 and the last thing you
want is to give up both of your B pawns
and allow the protected uh connected
passers oh no no no yeah that would be
dangerous so nehal is thinking for a bit
here probably deciding whether to play
Rook takes C1 yeah I don't think he's
gonna do that would basically Force
everything off but I like Rook B3 is
wait a sec is the niche going D5 D6 just
ignoring everything
he goes directly to first but I think in
general he does want to push his deep on
and he does and you for now you've got
to be really careful with white if you
lose the Deep on
you basically lose the game Jeffrey
given the time situation
so he just pushes it forward to D7
and he's threatening rookie too
ah after D7 yeah that would be no and
that's a trap Rook D1 so what if I go
like King
okay can you you bring the Rook back I
would start with H5 or maybe even G5 to
fix white spawns
yes
so he allows the repetition the question
is will nihal try to milk the clock here
and prevent another game from happening
I think that's what he wants in general
and he does A5
yeah indeed totally agree with that
General point for
yeah A4
do you go Rook B3 and B5 you just focus
on the queen said no he's gonna he's
gonna improve on all sides of the board
here yep and this is just great end game
patience of course and you should not
lose this game
but it's a Time scramble anything can
happen and the hall continues to make
small improvements to his position Rook
D3 check wait what if I give a check
yeah because King G4 Rook before
I guess what is G3 there maybe Ricky
she ate
you could checkmated here actually
yeah
three and then Rook B3 check
I mean I'm asking questions
asking some questions there
okay back to F2
okay I guess there's still nothing oh
wait D7 and rookie two rookie eight oh
he might have flundered that hold on is
it oh my God it might be losing for
black Rook H3
oh he finds the only way now Rook D5
check and rookie eight I think Rook D5
wins he missed it missed it rookie okay
wow Anish uh sorry Neil holding with the
skin of his teeth here oh Rook D5 check
for white ended the game there and now
it's anybody's game again
black might be winning whoa Rook G8
oh oh make a move
oh my God oh my gosh I think it's a Dr
D7 no but he's gonna win D7 isn't he
oh he is gonna win D7 oh my God is y
gonna lose this after all
holy smokes insane turn of events yeah
this is no fun for for Niche to hold now
it should be a draw though and nihal is
playing with 0.2 seconds on his clock
this might actually be the last game of
the match which is crazy of the segments
very likely very likely yeah the Hall's
making progress
yeah where did you go with the King here
it's
gotta guess and not to keep harping back
on this but this really reminds me of
that Rook end game in their cgc game
whoa here he goes King Venture into the
queen said but now oh it's over it's
Home Free he's just gonna win this Rook
H7
oh knee house or Geary's still trying
he's gonna move his Rook all the way
back but he's ain't that no that's it
you're not in time
that's it and I think you should
is there enough time to get in another
game I believe there is one more game
coming up wow
and I think it's Anish resigned
deliberately I think he was aware of the
match clock he's mad he wants to come
back he doesn't want to go to the
three-minute portion with a deficit
it really felt like I mean just a second
ago Anish was one showing tremendous
form up 3-1
but look at that nihal takes his first
lead in the match here
gritty win he might have been in trouble
for a second there but he just clutches
it I think he was losing on the spot
there for a second if he gave that check
and went rookie eight but that's what
knee Hall does that was ridiculously
Gutsy the way he managed to finagle
winning chances out of what looked like
a position White had zero risk in for
most of the game
incredible and I am really worried for a
nation bullet like that we were getting
a sort of preview that might foreshadow
further difficulties once the time
control starts speeding up
and it's less that he's losing on time
he actually is not flagging I think
Anisha has very good awareness of his
clock situation it's more that he's just
playing worse and he's getting more
nervous in the time scrambles and we
talked about it from the very beginning
that's where the experience level is so
important okay so nihal goes for his pet
line here Jeffrey but again I'm just not
finding his white openings all that
impressive
in the last couple tournaments he's
played he does try to lure you to sleep
almost yeah
before you know it he's all over you
but here's the one problem that I see is
that
that bishvanji said although the moment
that I mentioned it maybe you put this
bishop on H6 so it's not really a
problem
yeah I've lost a lot of games in this
type of structure with black against
knee-haul you don't feel like you're
worse at all you know you're not worse
you're probably even slightly better
objectively but it's hard to find
improving moves for black
right it's gonna be a slow maneuvering
game maybe a bishop D3 little tickle
because black is never ever playing F5
no
no name and now nihal is making progress
Queen B3 Knight C2
very symmetrical structure
step one was accomplished you kicked
that Knight away from its post
and slowly I think he'll start playing
on the queen side
yeah he loves the move A4 does knee Hall
these types of positions Queen B3
massaging poking prodding
and he's enjoying himself right now he's
got that one point lead for the first
time this match
this is a big game
and
I'm even wondering okay I think A4 is
the most natural move instinctively this
is the threaten A5 and keep softening up
uh squares to infiltrate but you can
always consider move like C4 as well
I'm willing to give I'm willing to give
you the isolated Pawn in exchange for
opening the C file and targeting uh that
weak point on C6
no that pawn I think you're right on the
money is is a massive long-term weakness
deciding to kind of play with his pieces
here using his Queen to induce more
weaknesses wait the Knight is saying I
didn't see that Bishop on H2 kind of
hiding in the shadows
yeah that ninja Bishop
I thought I was gonna propose A5
yeah
I'm I mean Knight B5 is the tempting
move you attacked the queen but the
Knight really
has no real purpose on that square but
he does go for it and now I think Queen
you could even play Queen B4 to continue
provoking weaknesses try to get black to
play A5 and soften up the B6 pawn and A4
by the way is a massive threat here it
traps the knife well sword yeah it is I
mean
sort of right sort of right
but as you said after A5 Queen B3 all of
a sudden B6 is a target you can't really
play Rook B8 because you'd line yourself
up with the bishop no it's it's crazy
how much progress he's made on the queen
side in the span of of five moves just a
second ago black was totally fine on
that side of the board now he's got to
move Rook B I think I thought there was
Bishop B5 yeah Bishop C7 Knight D5 do I
just win a pawn and then the Knight
jumps into E7 is what you're saying
exactly aha or queen takes B5 which
might be the safer way oh my goodness
okay I didn't see that bottom first
yeah I'm sorry to miss things I mean 95
Queen D7 yeah I agree with you you'd
rather take the beep on here
and yes it's nice to have the bishop
pair but not in this version I mean
these Bishops are sag both of them
did and one day White's gonna maneuver
that Knight on F3 around which is doing
nothing maybe go like via E1 D3
yeah this is it's just a clean Pawn
no this is a this has been a fantastic
early middle game for knee Hall and can
he convert this extra pawn and a minute
on the clock to boot
okay what now though how where is the
actual infiltration does he move the
Night Away From Evil I still like from
E3
uh yeah that is one idea I still
I don't like my 9 F3 it's being
dominated by the pawn F6 so I'm thinking
about maneuvering all the way around to
B5 even
uh-huh Knight H4 also an idea yeah but
that's very gimmicky I mean Knight H4
you're basically playing for these one
move tricks banking on some some uh some
crazy flash tactics yes I'm Rebecca
Harris tactics here but Knight H4 I
think it's actually hard to stop Knight
F5 and he could play it Jeffrey even if
black moves the bishop away from H6
Knight F5 still needs to be seriously
considered and rookie 7 streaming in uh
yeah and there's also a knight D5 rookie
7 idea might I add oh oh that is worth
showing Bishop G5 let's bring up
internet I keep my Nike my queen opens
E5 does it work
wait let me just work because I just
realized something if you take on E7 I
think on H4 I have Queen E4 with the
double attack oh my God and it's a
double attack as The Rook actually hangs
because the bishop is pinned this wins
the game
so the engine is saying that it doesn't
work and I think the reason might be a
queen move here maybe it's some sort of
Queen D6 so subtle
and the point is that if you play rookie
seven you drop the other night and you
can't take on G6 anymore so
this is worth calculating
and even here I think white is fine
but anyways I mean you still got two
pawns he goes rookie instead but there's
no that's not gonna cut it I think it
does my idea like what a call by you
Knight takes C5 ends the game
and he'll find him he's gonna find it I
mean he's he's wondering what what Anish
is uh what did he missed well Anish was
under the impression that Knight F5 is
the only night sound but fair enough yes
Knight takes D5 is game over rookie
seven and then Queen takes G6 using the
Knight on H4 not as a jumping off point
but as a standalone attacker
it's a move that the moment you see I
Feel Like Anything calculated you slam
it down and yeah I was gonna say
compared to the the stuff he found thus
far this is Child's Play
and this is getting really concerning
for Anya she is going to lose this game
and he's gonna find himself down two
points at the most inconvenient possible
point this break cannot come soon enough
and you can see it reflected in the body
language he is done with this game
I mean I would really feel distraught as
a niche because I feel like I've seen a
lot of stuff especially early on
he found the bishop F6 he found that
insane combination with Rook F3 in the
end but you're sitting here down two
points against Neil and perhaps your
best segment
not an easy feeling
it's been a tale of two halves first
half of the 45 first 45 minutes Anish
was in charge the second half nihal just
striking again and again he's got a
couple more moves to make here I think
97 97. nice
double attack on F5 and on G6
he goes rookie seven also good
also good
yeah take Queen D5 you just take on G6
F6
yeah mop the floor and Rook F7 is a
threat Anisha has had enough and he
throws in the towel
what a segment of Chess Jeffrey that was
amazing
so many beautiful ideas
from both sides but in the end I mean
nehal just coming up big that time
scramble I feel took the wind out of
anisha's sails last game that's why I
think he he struggled in this game never
really found his footing but yeah I mean
this is it's it's hard for for a niche
right now it is very hard for Anish to
scoreboard is updated knee-hal leads
five and a half to three and a half he
has opened up a two-point lead for the
first time this match and just when it
seemed like Anisha is going to be in
charge for this hour and a half all of a
sudden we are singing a very different
dude we are gonna go on a break but
first we wanted to remind you that
Alexandra garyachkana and zhangi tan
have reached the women's candidate
semi-finals only one of them will
advance out of full B and meet lateing J
in the women's candidates finals the
next match takes place Friday December
9th that's two days from now and all of
the action will be right here at
twitch.tv chess drop X Glam women's
candidates that's x-plan women's
candidates in the chat for all the
details you will not want to miss this
very high stakes day on Friday speaking
of high stakes we've got 60 Minutes of
high stakes three plus one to play here
at the speed Chess Championship we'll be
back with more action after this short
break
foreign
chess is that happening or not I haven't
seen it there's some smart people in the
camp so I wouldn't be surprised if
people
are versed at it really uh a lot of
college educated people you know I
unfortunately am not one of those
sophisticated people that play chess in
the camp she talking about man I don't
play chess
I mean you know how to play I listen
there's a difference with knowing how to
start a car up and then driving Formula
One racing
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
a storm is brewing Dimitri on Jacob the
Drake is a wizard within the Tempest the
best have come to test their skills and
brave the storm
oh we missed it oh yeah oh my goodness
the wheels the wheels have come out that
could be the match for some this is
familiar ground oh my goodness 98 whoa
for others this is a Fresh Field to
prove their prowess this is insane oh
look at Fabby exhausting every last
resource the battles will be Electric
Al tactic the moves will be fast it's
game over it's winning oh my God it is
he's gonna make a queen the stakes will
be high he just grabs his head he can't
believe it he just gave away the pawn
the 2022 speed Chess Championship is now
fasten your speed belts my friends we're
in for a wild ride
welcome back to the speed Chess
Championship GM Jeffrey Zhang and GM
Daniel nerdinski bringing you coverage
of today's round of 16 matchup between
nihal sarin and Anish Geary Jeffrey we
are as I said singing a completely
different tune now than we did just 40
minutes ago as nihal has Uncorked a
two-point lead on the heels of some
incredible play
and the this match was 3-1 in favor of a
niche which if I'm doing my math
correctly means that Neo has now gone on
a
four and a half half run since
they question can a niche bounce back
himself
and the change in time control only
favors one player that's very clear
nihal is happier the shorter the time
control they get now I can't say Jeff
Jeffrey that that Anish displayed some
major weakness in his time management
but every time they got down to a Time
scramble situation you could tell who
the more comfortable player was
precisely I feel like Anish knows this
which is why he might play like faster
than he usually would leading up to the
time scramble
But ultimately that puts more pressure
on his moves and he might make mistakes
because of that so we'll see what other
adjustments he's going to try to make
Maybe
try and
avoid nihal's tactics a bit
we'll see uh as we do see the game
starting if you figure out a way to do
that let me know
um well right now he's gonna have to
make an adjustment in the opening
because the last time they had this Karo
Khan Neal played F6 and won a sparkling
brilliancy with a double minor P sack in
the middle game so what has Anish
brought to the table here did he look at
this during the break
I feel like he has he's not really spent
any time yes at all and this is his okay
I now I understand he's not gonna take
on F6 and let black bring his Queen out
he's gonna say that if black tries to
get greedy here and take the 25 maybe
there's like a bishop
G4 in the Ender Bishop F4 just gaining a
tempo
I think that's a very impressive idea
and if Anish doesn't or if nehal doesn't
take any action and plays a move like
Bishop E7
then Anish could force the issue by
dropping his own Bishop back to F1
and putting massive pressure on this
weak E6 Pawn
right you would end up with a much
better version than their previous game
so he does play it though
Bishop D3 is that his follow-up and
Bishop D3 is a great move because it
also eliminates this very important
defensive piece on G6 I think that's
better than Bishop F1
and it's on the board
oh and
black clearly cannot play E5 to rid his
backward Pawn I mean due to clear
reasons here the King on E8 you would
just be uh
you'd be asking it's like all sorts of
trouble but on the other hand how do you
take care of this E6 weakness yeah and
these types of positions that weakness
could turn into a major strength if
black pushes E5 so white cannot rest on
his laurels
maybe Queen E2 maybe you play more
positionally with Bishop F4 try to
control the square in front of the pawn
now Black's gonna Castle King side I
would imagine
Jeffrey I don't think he's castling
Queen side here although Anything is
Possible
yeah both Queenie 2 and Bishop 4 look
very attractive to me ghost Queenie too
which begs the question can Neil get
away with E5 I would
almost surely not but
I don't know how how obvious how obvious
are things there well I think white
takes everything and goes F4 and then
drops the queen back
right I think it really isn't yeah there
really isn't much
well I can do there no not at all so in
order not to drop the money it was like
98. oh and then then you play Bishop F4
and totally dominate these Key Dark
squares in the center
that is nasty
yeah it seems like Anish is uh work over
the break I'm assuming is paying off
paying dividends
encouraged I love it when players you
know use the break diligently they don't
just go to bed for a couple minutes
which is nothing wrong with that but he
he was popping open Chess face he was
looking at his files and that's what
professionals do uh and that really adds
a nice wrinkle to these matches the
Hall's down to 40 seconds I don't see a
move he might have to just give up the
E6 pawn and castle and play an end game
upon down
I think he has to like I prefer that
option over 98 but yeah and he plays it
oh
that Bishop before
I feel like they're
they're quite a few ways you can play
this but he's gonna go the most mild
wages Bishop G3 maybe Queen D3 next and
double Rooks maybe get the other night
around oh that is a juiciest as if you
need another piece guarding the E5 score
which actually I think you do because
after Knight F7 black is finally ready
to play E5
I love that idea
and yeah
I mean you can also you can always throw
in a move like Queen C2 or queen D3 just
a tickle black
how exactly are they gonna be great
call I guess Queen F7 and now you can't
put an item no yeah exactly now you
can't put the Knight there and maybe
doubling Rooks on the e-file is yet
another way to defend E5 I mean how many
Defenders on that square are you gonna
have
you can really exhaust all the resources
if he's worried about G5 I was gonna say
you could play H4 but okay it does allow
it you could also play H3
then I think nihal is going to try Queen
H5
and maybe get a G4 and and you can't win
the game just by controlling the E5
screw you're gonna have to do something
concrete eventually
I mean yes you're gonna have to attack
something
I mean he always fights we know that
about him oh and he these types of
positions are actually the hardest I
think to bring him down in
when you're better positionally but he
just kind of shreds water and looks at
you and is like how are you gonna win so
right so once you get Knight H2
stops G4 but then you might allow a
knight F7 and E5 so he's gonna have to
give him this idea
okay so the king side is a little bit
opened up now
he goes Knight H2
but what's his follow-up does he want
Queen F3 and Knight G4
just I mean you're whoa content with the
end game ah Bishop C7 Robin in the
bishop visiting
the A5 Pawn which you might just snag
although 95 would run right into rookie
C8 and Bishop A5 maybe B6 so it's not so
clear there but this is what nihal does
he starts creating activity on the king
side great time management though for
Anish he's left himself with just enough
time I think to Parry all of the threats
maybe with Knight D2
yeah 92 would be a primitive way he does
go for it
note that the bishop defends H2 so
Knight F2 and queen H2 doesn't work
yes and you're all still trying he's
fine this feels a bit desperate yeah oh
oh my goodness oh some nasty
cutting off the Queen's defensive D5
pawn and if you have to go Rook D well
this is over windy foreign
everything's collapsing Knight D7 is
forced
and then yeah you can go rookie seven
Knight or Knight G4 you almost pre-moved
that
Rook D1
.
uh rickety you go F3 okay 95 wait a
second wait a second
I mean wait two and a half seconds
actually
Knight takes up six but then it gets a
little spicy and dicey King F6 F4
I don't know nihal still in it yeah that
loot last week perhaps stepped off the
gas hang on this is not this is not easy
I'm getting one of those feels when
nehal pulls off a ridiculous comeback
he's making progress with every move and
White's King is now permanently weak
he's just trying to create as much real
estate as possible for his pieces
10 seconds now for Geary
maybe go D5 D6 oh he just gives up the
pawn and he got does go D5
yeah I think just keep pushing it but
nihal has all these checks on the A7 G1
diagonal I mean he's been playing these
last 20 moves with one second it's equal
he just trades and wins the pawn back
no ridiculous
and now F5 another accurate move and
wait a second now Anish has to be
careful I mean wait a second he does he
does he has to be very careful
okay hold on so yeah yeah this is a draw
can you fly King B5 you are in time oh
by a tempo
but no how did he Salvage that and this
is just another entry in like the
classic vintage crazy knee-hall saves
lost position dead lost position and .2
seconds on the clock I said it was over
Jeff Jeffrey this is my fault I
literally said the game is over you
never say that
when nihal sarin is playing I don't know
why I haven't learned my lesson still
yeah you you might owe a niche
especially an apology after that Jinx
but
okay this one
and each plays F5 which I mean I
highlighted this in the game before like
you almost never want to play that and
give white access to this E5 Square
and clearly this is the second thing
that he looked up during the break was
this line and I think what he's saying
is congrats you have the E5 Square
but I've got the corresponding E4 square
and maybe even the F4 Square after the
trade of Bishops
it does feel very computer-esque to me
so I have no doubt that he checked it
but look at this idea from by niho he's
transferring the Knight on D3
and from there not only do you control
the F for square but you just you have
uh
both nights ready to hop in
no that's that's very very classy
positional chess and I think Jeffrey you
can relate to this experience of
checking a line of a stockfish and then
you come to the board and you're so
proud to play it and then you exhaust
your preparation and you're like wait
why is this not losing like because when
stockfish gives equality you're so
you're so under the spell that when you
don't have the eval in front of you
you know sometimes you begin to realize
that you just went for a very
impractical line and this might be the
case here I think an issue's position is
deteriorating
it can be so dangerous and yeah the key
word being the practicality of the
position some positions are equal when
the engines play it
but it's absolutely might not be the
case for for near humans
and I think this is a case in point I
mean you could trade and go G5
he goes Queen G5
which is a good movie he's trying to
generate maximum piece activity on the
king side to compensate for his weak
squares in the center
yeah but just he's to ah now he's got
Knight G5 ideas though
yeah it's gonna be Checkmate in like a
millisecond Knight G5 and Bishop takes
H3 is already a big threat
perhaps I didn't give a niche enough
credit I didn't see this all these
attacking ideas
yeah neither did I
and Neo has as you said some serious
problems to solve maybe it necessitates
some Bishop G4 move
right you can always simplify like that
worst case although could there be like
an f33 oh
maybe too much but you have to be aware
of all these ideas
there's all sorts of tactics there
Knight T2 Knight G5 I mean all it takes
is one of these Knight escapods
White's got a lot of things to keep
track of here on the king side
nehal with another one of his vintage
you know one and a half minute things in
a three minute game he doesn't care
just like it doesn't matter like when it
gets down to seconds
like I would be panicking but it's still
enough to play reasonable moves for
knee-hole somehow I would already be
panicking I'm not even exaggerating he
might actually end up spending something
on the order of 80 Seconds here let's
see when he makes the move he's out down
to a minute I think he's gonna go Bishop
G4 oh but Bishop G4 I could take on E5
can't I
so I think this is a more precise order
yeah he's gonna follow this up with
Bishop oh I believe what you're what
you're saying is that the Knight stands
E3 to Anchor itself to the F exactly
exactly so this now in this case it's
probably fine
okay so do you trade everything and just
go for the equal end game or does black
try to squeeze more juice out of this
with Bishop F5 or something like that I
think you squeeze the juice yeah you
squeeze it as much as you can down two
points here I'm looking at a move like
H5 as well
because then you would you would rid all
Queen G4 ideas for good yep get off me
forcing the bishop off of G4 I love H5
definitely black wants to keep Queens on
the board here given the king side
situation
calculating
you might be calculating these F3 Knight
G5 ideas I don't think they amount uh
just yet but he's making sure I think
it's important for Gary to play Fast
here oh
I don't like that H5 looks so good he
lets Neil off the hook and I have to say
white has the better chance than this
engine because the Knight on E5 is
permanent the 94 is not
that was a very poor decision for for
Anish to not play H5 I mean H5 it's not
like he's taking a big risk the
structure remains symmetrical he's well
in the end game
wait a second commentator
if you take on G6 it might be mate
rocate shade and Rook H5 actually is
made with the Knight covering F2
how does white defend you bail out yeah
you might bail with a move like G4
oh but this is three creating for his
King a pathway to F2 yes yes he escapes
just in time unbelievable nihal as usual
just making lemonade out of lemons you
can see Anish kind of squinting at the
position there like really I don't have
mate
yeah this is quite unfortunate even more
unfortunate when this Rook starts
invading along the E file
yeah there's just no checkmating ideas
and it so often happens that you're kind
of left with all of your pieces
clustered on an irrelevant side of the
board while your opponent's faces
infiltrate
down the abandoned open file
and now we've got a flat out time
scramble I think niho is going to take
this one
yeah these have not fared well for a
niche F2 King F2 simply
it's zeros according to the eval bar but
after rookie five I feel like
practically spilling it's no longer
zeros
yeah
the queen side too Knight C5 fb6
I just want to give like a little tickle
here with Knight D7 I I think what
Anisha is saying is that if White's Rook
one of white Strokes moves away from the
first strength black will have of course
the
Perpetual mating idea of Rook H1 Rook F1
uh-huh yeah that is what he's banking on
but nihal is going for checkmate himself
I don't think it's mate though what
about rookie H1 Rook H1 and then run to
H5
which I think niho might have missed
yes yes so this should still end in a
dream
or wait maybe
790 94. maybe he's gonna sack The
Exchange
still very unclear there uh it is black
could be better here I don't see a move
though
other than that before he plays it
you think nihal missed it
rugby one he's lucky I mean he's lucky
that or is he lucky no 96-94 he has Rook
H1 he goes 98 he tries to force
Perpetual but now Anish declines it no
there's no perpetually oh he's losing
all his pawns Rook B2 Rook G2
no now black is completely winning
rookie six though that might have been
an unnecessary capture there now is
there some midi net G4 no last thing
through no it's over
well I said that before now it's
actually over
yeah it's rookie
no they're just no no ideas here the
king Ventures you're all still trying
King G4
wait a second
just start pre-moving you've got okay
on his club that meant he played with
literally 0.0 left
how is that even possible goodness sakes
unbelievable I don't know how that's
possible how do you have less than 1.1
wow but what's important he picks up a
much needed win
holds back within one here
Ashish
and if you showed me the score of the
game I would have bet a silver dollar
the knee-haul was on The Winning Side of
that because that's how he wins his
games
great stuff by Anish not losing his
composure and finding Knight E4 in the
critical moment
huge
absolutely I am approaching sir I almost
jinxed it again I mean two ice in a row
would have been next level
oh man but
yeah now we see a slight adjustment made
by niho I think he got into trouble last
time he saw this when Anish got the F34
going
but he has Knight H5 played earlier on
so he's gonna eliminate White's Bishop
yep
and it's already a very kind of gritty
type of middle game position G6 wow
really Riley
is it going to take on E5 or just keep
the tension though
well I would imagine thanks yeah it
takes Queen D7
aha but what do you make of the Double D
Pawns in this kind of position
what do I make of the doubled e Pawns
well they can be both a strength and a
weakness obviously you can play F4 later
and you can use that as a pawn Mass
but at the same time when you play F4
you weaken the E3 Pawn black might have
F6 at some point I think it's a very
double edged but probably dynamically
balanced end game
it is I agree with everything which you
said there and I would like to play Move
Like E6 but I think after F4 there would
be Knight D4 Timber so that's biting a
little bit uh more than I could shoot
can I play
King C7
and first of all just to establish
you're defending against the massive
threat of E4 yes so Knights yeah oh
you've displayed it wait a second and
after F4
yeah I'd be very concerned about the
placement of that King there
and not only are you walking into Knight
D4 immediately you're also walking into
some ideas like E4 opened up the D file
first yeah you better have calculated
this accurately
yeah I think at least he guards the D4
Square
um
but still White's got King F3 and G4 on
tap just pushing all the pawns up
and if you play Knight G7 I guess you
beat him to the punch with G4
yes
and long term the idea is oh I was going
to say something else but he goes Knight
A4
should be six trading on his own terms
he wants that a file
nihal says no we're trading on my terms
yeah knights5 is nice because you're
gonna get a grip of that D4 Square
but so is F6 finally eliminating the
Splinter on E5 it was just sitting on
black
yeah important move Knight D4 just
casually drops the king back
not giving up the E5 Pawn without a
fight the problem is if you allow FeFe I
feel like
that it becomes more of a weakness than
a strength at that point even with the
f-file opening up
maybe yeah
right can you two I think it would just
have been met with a simple Rook hd8 so
he's gonna look for counter play
connected with that B7 uh weakness
so you can go for like a massive
liquidation you can take take and go
Knight E6 but
that's a very committal decision open up
the B file open up the f file you have
to be sure that white Strokes don't get
too active there
right on the other hand I don't see
another way other than eliminating this
diet on C5
yeah and white just threatens to take on
B7 here you don't want to go Rogue B8
that's for sure
and you walk into a fork on D7
I think you I think you have the right
idea I think you have to take and go 96
but without F take C5
without fe5 exactly oh but he plays fe5
I thought now they're going down the
line
is very tempting if you take on E6 first
I don't think you should do that he goes
for F6 straight away
okay but what's the follow-up rook hg8
and Anish just smoking okay
yeah I thought I was gonna get my net
and F5 but it doesn't necessarily lead
anywhere
okay
Anish may be at a dead end here
I want Rook like Rook D6 at least to
keep Rooks maybe three in one day
can I say I I don't know problem is also
that there were these Forks ideas 94
Knight C3
yeah probably those ideas weren't really
coming into fruition
it's still double edged I mean plus two
be that as it may
but nehal has his work cut out for him
if he wants to win the send game maybe
H5 maybe just I love H5 you would
threaten Rook Cafe a monster threat oh
because you're stopping G4 no he goes
King E6 straight away
the pawn
I don't know I think he wants 94.
oh
and if one I guess he he cleans up the a
pawn and you would have three connected
passers there yeah he's judged that the
night end game is winning I'm not
totally sure about that I think it's
very double-edged
okay yeah he goes Knight A2 okay maybe
too many passers
no white needs to just
let's get things going here maybe you go
H4 just even ignore the E Pawn and would
you bring the king up let's say to D2 to
delay at least as much as possible the
progress of Black's Pawns
ah such a tough call I feel like
intuitively I would just push h4h5 I
hate being on either side of these types
of end games because I literally have no
idea what to do like do you push the
pawns do you bring the king back
he goes Knight G4 so he clings to all of
his pawns and he wants H4
because this is an old-fashioned race
yep you need to beef well there we go
okay yeah he has to he has to use the
king
I would throw an H4 while you still have
time
right he can still get away with it for
one move
but maybe it's just concretely lost
because that a pawn comes in to join its
friend or the oh and also the C Pawn
also the C no there's just way too many
passers oh b3903 Knight C1 oh what a
tactic that would be but I guess he he
doesn't really need it he can play it
now he can play C4 here white is way too
slow
maybe I guess he takes E5 you can keep
it simple here just take on E5 and run
the king back love that move that's such
a classy move and of course nihal plays
it
classy is his up is up his alley
it's over so yeah that's all she wrote
c3c2 C1 goodbye
another really nice and gameplay just a
fantastic win with the black bases for
any Hall that was a smooth game
absolutely wasn't I was thinking like
when King E6 appeared that white would
be the one with the initiative but the
moment he played F6 chipping away at
that Center is where things started to
turn around yep
no you're absolutely right that was the
turning point
and I've always been impressed with
nehals and game play he is just an
endgame juggernaut
doesn't matter worse better he will find
all of the chances to be found
okay the last game before the halftime
break here and interestingly a niche
allowing a perk Jeffrey and kind of
meeting it with C5 creative approach for
black yeah I feel like he took a page
there out of niho's book I seem to
recall Neil himself
essay in these perk positions in that
Global matchup
but a slightly
different approach here by Annie she
goes C5 we get this sort of structure
where black is trying to bring the
Knight into F4
things very King's indian-esque
yes
wean E3 okay so nihal hits the pawn on
C5 kind of necessitating B6
right I'm expecting a simple response E6
probably rookie one
maybe Knight F4 you can throw in but the
bishop just has C2
right but I was thinking you do include
that because with the bishop F1 you
control the diagonal while if I had
relegated the Bishops to C2 maybe I'd go
like a bishop a six
I've lost a lot of Blitz Games to any
Hall and these types of structures but
the extenuating factor is that Bishop H6
oh that could have nasty looking move
the queen is nice Queen has oh it
doesn't but you can play King H1 and
somehow there's no easy way to defend
the bishop only moving each one but King
G7 white moves the Knight out of D2 God
Neil's a magician
I don't know somehow yeah
I have no idea if he stumbled onto that
idea where he just got where I mean he
saw it coming from a mile away but seems
like he's getting away and
now for black how do you deal with the
PIN
that's the million dollar question I
actually feel like if you're a niche you
might have to move the bishop back while
it's not too late otherwise you might be
the one getting stuck
it's crazy that black might be the one
who gets
pin the queen is pinning the bishop on
H6 which is a rare thing to say usually
it's the other way around
and he does yeah he doesn't see anything
better wise decision for Anish I think
at least you're not gonna blunder a
piece and here maybe he's still got
ideas of attacking with E5 and F5 just
playing King's Indian style
's like what was that
E5 who
well at least here Black's got that open
diagonal to work with
I'm not sure about E5 that is a very I
wouldn't call it a bad move it's a
committal move
yes and Anisha is very easy play here
right Bishop B7 Rook d a maybe Rook D5
so it's up to nihal to create some
activity he sacks the pawn whoa what's
his idea Knight takes E5
Knight F3 there's made on H2 watch out
and the problem is if you play 95-95
there's Queen takes C5
I think he might have blundered that
yeah yeah definitely the other line yeah
the other line Knight C5 Knight F3 Queen
F3 you could take on A8 but your queen
would be which would simply stuck there
great awareness by Anish there
not trusting his opponent
and a big Pawn blundered there by nihal
Bishop B7 is coming
this could get real dicey
yeah what kind of compensation exists
just Bishop B7
it's gonna play slow
love the confidence with which Anish is
carrying out the last few moves no
compensation here that much is obvious
and as Queen takes E4 a threat here
because you would have Rook D1 at the
end pinning
down white completely
maybe before you know it the bishop
comes back to H6 for a different reason
that time
as New Hall tries to seek his Fortunes
in the end game
yeah this is nice because you make use
of a potential pin along the d8 G5 you
know you no longer have like Knight G5
and E6 which would have been uh ideal
oh if you could have gotten that in you
would have been you know borderline
winning
I'd see seven super nice though leaving
the Knight on G5 kind of in the dust
oh so I what if this yeah what if Bishop
for
wait can you take and take E7
right the idea of thinking what is the
idea well nihal has the same question
I guess he's gonna say
yeah he still has the bishop pair here
so definitely black for choice
but I feel like he slipped Just a Touch
and now he's low on time as well
so the Knight has F3
uh-oh id6 even
now F6 is a frustration move yeah things
have gone terribly wrong yet again for a
niche
and now with the queen side pawns all on
dark square is I think new Hall's may be
the only one with winning chances here
a4a5 comes to mind
keep that Rook on C6 also you apply a
lot of pressure on the pawn chain
exactly Rook has C6 if necessary
yeah I think we're gonna see it
now A5 is even stronger uh oh
and that Bishop 4 is dominating its
counterpart look at the poor Bishop on
G7
a niche has to try to get this Rook off
of C6 maybe go rookie eight rookie six
as quickly as possible
but then A5 might come
at an inopportune moment
yeah there's even you can go like
afterwards you can go a b and Rook C8
and black will have to play a B
you're right he's gonna play a takes B6
I think or maybe there's another Rook
there's another idea too you can take
everything go Rook A6 and then B4 maybe
just go after the pawn oh go after that
B6 pawn another great idea Neo dropping
down to eight seconds there I think he's
opting for your idea good call uh-huh
great at least here he can never ever
lose
he goes on the other side okay this
makes sense and maybe now before
no still keeps the tension
he's dominating the light squares
positionally
yeah he's trying to drag
a nation to get another time scramble
but now Neal is the one down to five
seconds
which evidently is an eternity for me
it's like an hour Bishop D4 Bishop D4
great defense
still this Rook end game is
far from Easy we've seen you all win
these I would put the pawn on B6 and
start bringing the king over
yes
King F3 make a Mad Dash for it
hang on
no but this is a draw isn't it this
should be a draw unless I'm missing a
trick
if you play H4 though you might be
weakening the G4 Square I don't see how
nehal's gonna win this
yeah it's true would always be met by G4
I think
yeah you don't want to allow the a past
F Punk for white that's actually super
important yeah great call and anytime
the king hits C6 you start checking from
the back
oh
still rugby one's still under control
there's no Rook trades I mean every Pawn
end game is a draw yes
oh my gosh
okay back to home base
okay yeah now G4 yeah that's the key
and you've got the king fully cut off
fully cut off
right but if you get the G5 there's Rook
B5 always yeah there's never any zugs
ones and Niche has enough Mouse skill I
think to hold this together
Rook B6
oh
still trying
he's also milking time off the clock
which is totally valid totally valid
oh wait oh my God why did the bar go up
there why is it
okay rookie seven oh okay
no one smokes
he still has it or no no no now it's a
draw
I gotta show that
yeah
wait okay don't start the next game guys
it's uh it's it's halftime break okay so
let me fast forward all the way
to
wait where was the win
I was right around here I think with the
King on D6
we get it there there we go right here
so here rookie8 is winning for white
unbelievable but this Pawn end game
because of the king placement blacks
can't get shouldered
what the heck here here
here
goodbye Pawns
that's the type of idea I think everyone
in the room missed except I mean maybe
uh only perhaps Magnus would have
you know sense such a moment but Magnus
Magnus would have seen that from the
moment they went into the Rook end game
but you can't fault me hall for missing
that it was a big chance though he would
have been up by three still he's more
than happy to keep the two-point lead
with which he started the three-minute
segment Anish still with his work cut
out for him Jeffrey it's gonna be a
tough ride I think Anish atla very least
has to try to erase this lead going to
the bullet
totally agree yeah you want to restore
you want to restore uh as much as you
can
and for sure
yeah and uh we're gonna see if he's able
to do that he's got 26 minutes more of
three plus one action folks you're
watching the speed Chess Championship
back with the rest of the three plus one
on the other side of this short break
[Music]
International Master Danny wrench back
again Chief chess officer bringing you
chess terminology let's Dive Right into
one of one of everybody's favorite
tactics if I might be so bold because
it's surprising it's something that
never never fails to deliver shock value
and excitement whether you're watching a
broadcast or just reviewing some famous
chess games and that is the process of
an under promotion when you move upon to
the other side of the board almost
always you're looking to get a queen but
the rare times where it's better to get
something else or perhaps even required
in order to maybe not stalemate your
opponent or keep your winning chances
alive are some of the most fascinating
exciting moments in chess so with that
let's dive into what under promotion is
and show you some of my favorite
examples under promotion as we said is
the process of promoting a pawn but not
to the most obvious or most powerful
type of piece which is usually the queen
in this famous example between Nakamura
and Vladimir kramnik the fact that
Hikaru was winning is only because he
under promotes on C8 to a knight that
move comes with check on the black king
so that on the next turn white can
capture the E2 pawn it should be noted
that if Hikaru had queened
black would actually go on to win
because now black queens with check and
ultimately chromic would have been able
to not just save but actually win this
game another promotion tactic provided
to me by our own Sam Copeland vice
president of content one of his favorite
examples is the move D7 and after Bishop
to E8 the only way to win the game is to
underpromote to a bishop under voting to
a bishop doesn't happen that often in
this particular study it was designed to
be so the point is that if the bishop
moves over to H5 we check and mate along
the A4 E8 diagonal and if the bishop
moves anywhere else white actually plays
a subtle move Bishop of seven first and
there is no way to prevent Checkmate on
the next move shout out to everybody
watching this video thank you for tuning
in and enjoying our breakdown of under
promotion and we'll see you on chess.com
[Music]
thank you
thank you thank you
welcome back to the speed Chess
Championship we are watching a
fascinating match between Newhall Sarah
and annish Gary as nihal leads seven and
a half five and a half let's take a
quick look at his Insight Card his
matchup card alongside Grand Master
Jeffrey Zhang Jeffrey Zhang his
reputation precedes him what more do we
need to say about nihal
it's been truly a joy to watch so far
he's come up with electrifying ideas
left and right when he gets low on time
he's kept his composure just so so
impressive and yeah as we pointed out
earlier the two time jscc Champion I was
a regular participant
myself so I know how hard that is to win
but to win it twice nothing short of
amazing
yeah he is a very very deserving
participant but of course Anish giri
he's displayed some pretty awesome
ability to manage time scrambles I don't
think he's doing anything systematically
wrong and the quality of play in this
SEC match has been incredibly High all
around we've gotten positional battles
we've gotten long end game grinds and of
course we've gotten some beautiful
tactics from both sides okay Anish has
the white pieces he's got to come back
to make let's see what he can do with
the white pieces
yeah knee-hole keeps
keeps uh going with the H6 means Gambit
this worked out very well for him in the
last game when he jumped with Knight H5
I think he's going to repeat it
um
okay so maybe you go H3 uh okay I
expected an H3 inclusion there just to
uh to avoid many truck because I thought
Niha was quite happy with this
this kind of smacks of
preparation as well Knight to G3
obviously G5 doesn't trap the bishop you
have that E5 Square
which the bishop has availed itself of
in previous games
yeah they're running a similar line to
to this other game where niche I believe
it was quite favorable he achieved E4
slightly different though but I still
don't really like this for black I feel
like white is actually spoiled for
Choice here you could go Knight F5 or
you could take on C5 and get that iqp
structure that they've had previously
and in both cases I think white is
better
totally agree and in this scenario I
might
have more of a liking towards Knight F5
just because
I don't know for for whatever reason I
feel like I'm never worried about C4
I've always got
E4 ideas myself I've also got a G4 G5
idea
um that I could see so oh totally and
he agrees with us and just to illustrate
how quickly this could get unpleasant if
we could bring up the analysis word real
fast C4 Queen D2 let's say black plays
something nonchalant like A6 how quickly
this attack unfolds E4 and before you
know it White's already grabbing on H6
and delivering Checkmate I mean you can
see the Evo bar shooting up
whenever you've got a knight on F5 and
you've got control of the center you
just cannot mess with these types of
ideas I think Neil has to tread very
carefully the next couple of moves to
avoid getting into a position like this
and he goes fantastic illustration
and here again there's a choice to
simplify you can take when he's seven
just play against the iqp but I like
keeping attention
and keep the tension he does now c4
looks a little bit more appealing due to
the possibility of Bishop f8 to guard
the H6 font and preclude the immediate
possibility of E4 he goes Bishop f8
straight away though keeping his options
open
yeah I still don't think you have to
rush maybe quiet move like Queen B1 just
keeping all all the doors open
you might
spring and E4 at some point maybe DC
it's black can never really go G6
themselves so that Knight is is there to
stay on F5
speaking of open doors he's trying to
open some doors on the queen side is
Anish giri his intentions are Violet
Knight C7 Knight bd6
a lot of weak dark squares on that side
of the board
well I didn't even notice this
suddenly hello
suddenly there are all kinds of stuff
like Knight H5 was was my initial
thought but you can now move the bishop
out of the bishop C7 or Bishop D6
yeah Bishop C7 Queen G5 things get very
spicy here
but it's not all one-sided I mean
White's pieces are kind of loose
as well and maybe C4 should be thrown in
at some point I'm not sure
I think you have to
but after the queen Retreats you don't
really solve all your problems there's
still many night jumps to account for
not to mention yeah the D5 Pawn is a
long-term weakness
so he manages to refrain
from C4 maybe he wants to keep C4 in
reserve as an intermediate move actually
Bishop takes f8 C4 as possible
whoa okay I'm trying to calculate and
I'm starting to get a bit confused what
if I yeah actually it's not clear what
you even take with wait 97 this is this
low 97 oh that's a big blunder there
that's a big Pawn you cannot afford to
lose
whoops
and that's a byproduct of the pressure
that Anish has been putting all game
long
yeah there are way too many ideas to
worry about
not surprisingly he forgets about this
but it's still okay he's still gonna try
and
wiggle around
I mean what happened we seen from the
all night bc3 another nice move by Anish
solidifying and securing his Knights now
they defend each other
at some point I'm expecting
I'm expecting him to take on D4 I don't
think he can
really leave that there for long
and nehal trying to you know get the
spark plugs going on the queen side he
wants B5 chipping away at the edges
that's basically all he can do here
with that monster
sitting on D5
right yeah not really not much maybe you
have to take on D4 Knight F6
yep good call
it's only a pun so that's what he's
telling himself it's only a pun
but yeah I mean the whole structure so
powerful with coupled with that net on
D5 was Rook F2 trying to triple stack
here on the default
right although Knight C5 prevents it
Knight B3 is a four keep
carefully brings the queen back to E3
doesn't each love the way F5 F5 Rook C2
oh that was the dagger
yeah now you can't play it because of
97. wait ah no 94 Rook D2
yeah otherwise that ended the game on
the spot
so maybe move the king away but that
walks you into some checks he goes King
H1
okay
fair enough I think Anish just wants to
keep the pressure on Neil getting low on
time
eventually I would consider setting the
F Pawn in motion now obviously that's
very risky because you're weakening the
E4 Square E4 pawn and that anchors your
knight
so maybe just keep the tension as long
as possible no there's that four three
is a concession
okay but yeah
I think you go f yeah I think he does
want to play F4 but he's making every
possible useful move before that wait
that doesn't work though F4 F4
oh wait no no what do you mean yeah
yeah I don't need a case of
this is a very tough position so I just
implicitly trusted him yeah yeah
no wait that made no sense he's still in
the game though B5 B4
uh nihal loves playing with point two
seconds on the clock Knight C5 wait
he's somehow still creating some chances
he is Knight D3 all of a sudden yeah but
here comes the g-pawn
GH this has to be winning Rook D2 Queen
G4 still not easy or King's open White's
King is Knight C4 almost works oh almost
there's a queen G3 there that was
literally the only move
it's still not over
not Rook D7 though no but there's
rookies and and just Queen D3 just get
the Queen's off the board yeah yeah go
go go hold on Queen two seconds
it's not easy to break through this
night
oh Queen back to C6
oh my God oh my God you can see three
okay that forces the queen trade ah nice
now I think now he's probably got it
there's still a possibility to get
forked though
gives up before he's gonna have one Pawn
left but that's enough careful
yeah and this should be winning
it's not the easiest one in the world
though for something
I mean outside of that you just bring
your king through I think in G4
yeah and you know what you can do in
such positions you can sack on D7 at the
right moment and okay squawk run out a
great defensive effort but
credit to a niche he kept his composure
it was never in doubt
I mean whenever Niche gets down to one
second it's my heart races for him it's
it's just a contrast like when a niche
gets low on time I'm never worried but
yeah you mean when you haul oh sorry one
knee-hole excuse me yeah but the other
way around it's just I never know when
you know if your hand trembles you just
flag there no totally and and it's it's
no knock on anisha's bullet skills which
are impressive but you just know nehal
has it under control and he's got no
time on his clock you're absolutely
right okay another jababa London weird
kind of setup
this time it's Anish taking the first
long think
oh what a close game
what a close watch
it's only a big win the point match
yeah you get it back to one
I think as we were sort of alluding at
the start like even a tied match heading
into bullet would significantly favor
niho so Anish is gonna try whatever he
can here to try and turn around this
match entirely
definitely a little 2-0 or 3-0 run here
to end the three-minute segment would go
a very long way
toward increasing its chances now big
decision here JX whether to take on G3
and allow that H file to open up
he wants none of it
as he gets his Bishop out to F5
yeah I guess he sees no reason to rush
there not really worried about Bishop 5
you play F6
so
yeah in this scenario
I think it's with the c Pawn which is
interesting
which you often see in these types of
lines I guess creating this weird kind
of
Juan mass in the center
which is nice hard to say whether it's a
strength or a weakness A3 to restrict
the Knight
it is nice and solid that's what I can
say about it I I like the look of C5
here for black I feel like that's also
very a niche style because he's a
grunfeld player
opening up the bishop yep and then maybe
snap off at Bishop on G3 actually maybe
do it first and then play C5
think either or is fine
yeah I agree with you dc5 I would just
take on G3
not enthralled with any with nihal's
position maybe throw in Bishop B5 and
try to induce F6 and just go back
yeah it is an idea I wasn't sure whether
or not he does for it I didn't know if
this actually weakened Black's position
or strengthened it yeah
give me that diagonal give me that
square says neho
this is a huge concession isn't it like
take on D4 what if I go Queen
I'm trying to calculate yeah yeah
exactly me too
I think
yeah Knight A4 you take on D4 and eight
the A1 Rook would hang at the end yeah
everything drops there and worse comes
to worse you could fly down in exchange
for two Pawns
no that's out of the question
wait what does white do
maybe 92 is not so bad
okay he's played it
take on B2 though
like still Rook B1 Queen A3 I don't know
oh okay very positional restricting
the Knight on E5 and obviously
preventing what was already a big threat
of Knight D7
hmm
interesting position do you go B4 do you
waste the tempo to defend the pawn
yay defense in another way which is good
annoyingly for black you can't go Knight
C6 which is the movie you want to play
don't want to take on E5 either that
would leave H6 hanging
I suppose you could play Rook d8 he goes
Rook C8 same type of idea to prepare
Knight C6
now I'm looking for a way
for white to start some sort of attack
here on the king side like with G4
um yeah G4 looks interesting
is it too slow though like you can even
rack with F4 and I'm not sure what I'm
doing
or even ignore with Knight C6 ignore it
completely yeah just say you're too weak
in the center
to justify any serious kingside plan you
know niho might just have to Castle
kingside and accept a worse position but
no he doesn't he goes Queen E3
so still Knight C6 met with Knight D7 oh
that's a that's a sick idea
and then E6 Falls with check
okay right so a news takes debate we'd
be two castles grab time
but he's not you're just gonna drop back
and here comes anisha's Rooks or nihal's
Rooks
right I am the one
very ever so slightly concerned because
again Knight C6 always met with Knight
D7 in this case Knight C5 would hit the
queen with Tempo E6 would be hanging
so yeah the black it doesn't feel ease
and make moves like even after a quiet
one such as rookie one
yeah just kind of emphasizing as you're
indicating the fact that provided that
black and never go Knight C6
it's definitely concerning for a niche
and maybe a a Brute Force move like
rookie 8 is is what the doctor ordered
here you have to try to get Knight C6
and you can't play without your queen
side
but he's down just 25 seconds
imperceptibly he's dropped down on the
clock and I'm always worried
when you've got this amount of time in a
sharp middle game incredibly tricky
position rookie 8 maybe there's like
okay he goes Rook C7
this also stops the Knight D7 response
so he he does want to play either night
6 or Knight D7 and if he makes that move
the position becomes a lot easier to
play and then he can rattle off a bunch
of moves quickly like rookie yay
obviously A3 is going to be hanging
great point but what if I play Rook C1
here I Rook ec1
and then if Knight C6
oh I assumed that I would have
you know but maybe not you almost have
Knight D7 it doesn't quite work out
okay now getting a long time he's trying
to figure out what what sort of Tricks
he has we're gonna get an old school
time scramble here but I don't see a
clear way to muddy things up with white
okay repetition ugly repetition of moves
I don't think any should take it though
Queen D6 just make a stabilizing move
was the other way around yeah now he
should be in the clear he should be able
to develop the Knight for sure
G4 beautiful luck everything in he has
to deliver in this game this is a very
winnable position it's a must
it's just everything's solid rooksy wait
a minute oh three Rook C8 he's still
holding
still holding oh my God desperately
mudding the waters but Knight takes D4 I
think works out for black
yeah there are no Perpetual ideas the
King Slither the Slither just take back
through Rook takes CC thinking about it
no he blunders what is this one I forgot
he didn't forget it
and I was gonna point this out don't
take on E6
tragedy
oh that is a that is a knife right there
that is a dagger
I mean when you would have been talking
yeah we would have been talking about a
tied match
no that's a two-point swing right there
and and Jeffrey when he started thinking
after Rook takes C7 I got that knot in
my stomach that he's about to make a
blunder
oh
my goodness nehal pulls out another
insane comeback win
and he still has that pesky two-point
lead
yeah that is that is going to be a tough
pill for Muse to swallow
unbelievable so
all Theory now qga they've showing uh
yet another opening in this match and I
think
there was a recent game here oh 94
not sure what I make of this
yeah I guess Rook takes C5 is something
we're working with that one
that was in the air and now
what if ba foreign six a lot of stuff
hanging in that line I like this from an
anti-tilt perspective you've got an end
game relatively low risk
this is a very dangerous time for Anish
was that just like four Moves In A Flash
yeah how did A3 Rook a like pre-moved
come on what
and it's fan of settings yeah I I
couldn't uh couldn't understand what was
going on but any case this resulting
position does look
pretty dryish Fabi says he made the same
blunder against you in title Tuesday I
was actually watching her stream it was
like a long trading sequence and at the
end there was a defended piece
yeah exactly that was a very fortunate
moment for me but just an easy one to
miss sometimes we forget how the knights
move I guess
I forget it on a daily basis okay so has
the position
more or less stabilized and does white
still have a slight advantage
probably ever so slight the pawn A6
just a tad weaker than its counterpart
on A3 you also have the nice Knight on
A5
and the new the nuclear option is to
play Bishop B4 at some point
the problem there is white Black's just
going to trade everything and go Rook V8
and I don't see why it went right
yeah black speech found D5 also a
monster
okay they've switched
to some abstract kingside Pawn play as
nehal grabs some space with a G5
and basically asks Anish how he plans to
improve his position
okay there's the answer
now can Neal play a move like Bishop D6
here
I'm trying to see if I can give up yeah
give up the a palm get some some counter
play
okay Bishop
so he's basically trying to prevent
white from doubling on the C file in a
good
version you could play Rook C3 here not
out of the question
and he plays it yeah keeping the Rooks
on the CFL makes a lot of sense
still like long lasting pressure yeah
black has to be very careful not to drop
that pawn on A6 not to allow
Rook takes C5 if the Knight moves great
point and then the Knight drops back to
B3 at the end picking off The Rook
hmm
not easy to find a move here of your
knee-haul you gotta step very lightly
here
yeah not not at all I'm trying to see if
I can exit the pin because like doubling
is is a massive threat I have to deal
with what about Rook
cb8 can I get away with such a move
okay so he takes the concrete approach
allowing the check on B4
and of course his idea is Bishop takes
A6 Rook A8
yes right we'll probably not be able to
get away with that
although Bishop B5 there
can you actually take on okay I was
additional
yeah I was also trying to understand
that that line
but yeah okay he's going against 90.
he's gonna get Knight D6
for the bishop pair
that's such a big deal though like I
take
playwork C6 yeah congrats would you like
a metal like where's the actual
advantage
okay Rook D1 right
very kind of grindy game
yeah lots of subtleties again 95 Bishop
C3 if Knight B6 there's Bishop takes E5
so the obvious moves have flaws
yup
okay we have a trade and there's Bishop
D5
so Knight D6 Knight A5
a couple of items on the menu here for
white but Knight D6 Rook C6 just looks
very watertight for black
yeah not sure exactly how to increase
pressure on A6 I would go Knight A5
95 Rook ba call it a day
yeah it might be that about that time of
the day maybe Rook D4 pretend that
you're still trying
but but after Rook B6 I'm not sure why
White's playing for a win at that point
yeah but white might be playing for a
loss there
the Knight does get stuck like solves
its only issue yeah
it's time for B5 just bail it out
I would bail out 30 seconds
I'm starting to get a little bit ever so
slightly concerned for Anish I'm worried
too because like Knight C4 I take it and
play A5
yep
okay now
ah F3 is an interesting cagey kind of
move preventing or taking this thing out
of f4
uh-huh income still probably
balance but
it's now easier for black to navigate
this
oh no question about it
maybe like H5 H4
and a niche offering a draw interesting
decision time for knee Hall I mean I
would it would make sense to take it
keep the two-point lead
but he smells blood oh he says no yeah
he smells blood
okay and you says what exactly are you
smelling he's down to 15 seconds maybe
it's time to make that draw after all
10 seconds
I think he feels so comfortable in these
time scrambles and chief where he
launches he's making inroads he's gonna
win the pawn back with interest and that
Knight on A5 Jeffrey is really out of
the game
oh my this is not easy to handle uh Rook
this is
looking at like Rook D1 but then Rook
before
yeah you can't even move Knight takes
two course coming for a second you can't
find anything
that G4
whoa whoa what a move and he's gonna
have the past day pawn at the end
and that Knight is still stuck totally
stuck and now you've got holes on the
dark squares
oh my which he tries to cover with his
King maybe bishop B5
H3
they're still H3 yep goodbye wait
yes Bishop
just another remarkable
find and sequence by neho and this is
Jeffrey to Echo your point even scarier
than the three-point lead he's opened up
is how this bodes for newhall's uh for
anisha's chances in the bullet he he
just can't lose every one of these time
scrambles because he's not gonna make it
out of the gates in the bullet segment
I'm trying to recall a single game that
in each one where they're both like down
to 15 seconds and
and I can't
so this is
yeah I mean I saw Fabi there was was
saying a niche might be underestimated
in bullet but
all these games uh don't leave a great
impression oh I mean
as we said at the beginning Anish grew
up playing Blitz in the park he's he's a
very experienced bullet player in
general
but when we talk about knee-haw we talk
about a different level of bullet
mastering and the guy just does not make
mistakes in time scrambles which is
crazy
and yet another job London I'm just let
me get sick of this but me too and I
played it for years
yes still the same G5 Bishop G3 whoa oh
a Twist here
little Tabasco sauce added to the
position with 95.
I don't know about G5 because H4 could
come real fast here
yes striking and opening up all the
Avenues
well
black has to smooth Knight F4 which I'm
trying to evaluate
it's a typical idea in these lines
two can play at that game is what you're
saying there
weakening the D4 Pawn
yeah I don't really know
if that's what you want to do but it
certainly is on the table
yeah I like Knight F4 but Anish is sunk
into a Monumental thing
and it should be six is possible
Ah that's what he's thinking about I was
wondering like what is the delay I don't
yeah for it right I think Bishop H5 is
just the modest way and but maybe I mean
Bishop A6 and Goku Village five
yeah six I I'd probably go Knight F6 but
yeah ultimately he goes he was the
normal way about it he was
okay Bishop F5 by Anish completing his
development
at 9986 rejoined Society either by it B4
or C7 but it's gonna take it a while to
really get back in the game I like
White's position
I do too that H Pawn also feels like a
long-term weakness
obviously smells blood a a victory in
this game would
uncork a four point lead and it would be
an absolute dagger
yeah things would be getting out of hand
okay there's F4
cementing the Knight
okay Knight C7 looks pretty solid for a
nation he could even go 98 Knight F6 or
98 Knight D6 and play against these
light squares in the center
trying to construct an idea for white
how to Target the H Pawn I think he's
doing the same maybe you okay I was
gonna say I was going to suggest Bishop
H3
and queen H5 but this is similar like
he's got the queen H5 in and even you
might Retreat Knight F3 just to go after
the age Pawn I was gonna say queen H5
looks like a big positional threat I
would even play it now
Rook F3 as you said
and to borrow your phrase things could
get out of hand very quickly on the king
side here and there it is
I wouldn't put any stock in the eval bar
here I like White's position
yeah me too
for black it's also difficult to suggest
some counter play
what exactly do you I mean can you do
anything in the meantime you could try
to prepare C5 which is of course the
sort of traditional idea
in in such positions but who's going to
play a move like Rook C8 here that's not
very human
oh Bishop G sexy blunder this queen oh
he blundered his Queen
oh my well technically people entered a
piece because there's Knight H6 okay
Anish Anish he has to find don't you
dare Miss Bishop G6
okay I'm getting really seen it yet yeah
he's not seen it yet no this is but it's
it's staring at him in the face
because otherwise Knight H6 you
literally have to find this the only you
have to find it the only other news is
maybe Queen D6 but but now what worries
me Jeffrey is that even after he plays
Bishop G6 he's gonna have 20 seconds
what's he doing oh yeah it's not over he
doesn't
no just doesn't see it I mean he's
worried about Bishop okay finally wow
finally played it with 20 seconds left
but now the game is actually far from
over given nihal's abilities and time
scrambles
yeah you take on H6 here you play Queen
F3
Still Force and each to keep his nerves
in I see him shaking his head like what
took me so long yep but better late than
never and he's up a full piece and he
can attack on the king's side now King
H7 Rook G8 is very strong now this is
winning
this is like busto
undoubtedly but why do I spell another
twist I can't blame you for that Knight
G4
I don't know about Bishop D3 I don't
love that move
are starting to creep up again
I mean it is still a full piece up at
the end of the day but
there's one thing I know about knee-hole
especially this match what I think you
might have missed here Rook H3 Knight 65
and very important move Rook G4
because if we use the H4 Pawn then the
game becomes legitimately complicated
now I think it's basically over
Queen H5 I mean okay
very easy gonna take it naturally a very
gingerly guy A6
stop the counter play
but it's time it's time yeah Queen H5
Rook G8 bring everybody in
yep all the toys to the nursery party
there he goes how is he gonna break
through on the Kingston yeah I think the
Hall's trying to set up some sort of a
fortress he is he's setting up Fortress
here I mean the extra piece
oh it's an Unstoppable threat with the
epon hanging too I think Queen X1 was a
possibility no Rook H3 GH
oh there's still no way through somehow
wait how do you have to open the queen
side Go Beast and then I get to go yeah
yeah you just play for play for A5 or
some break there and use the possibility
of Rook takes H3 to Anchor to tie
White's Queen down
to the second rank
yeah and you should have this in the
bank
oh is he gonna he's dragging this out oh
he's walking the king all the way around
I mean he has no you gotta go B6 or A5
or something
open up the queen side
wait now white can go A5 this is
all I mean it's just a little bit
unconvincing here that it's got me
worrying and I don't know why he
procrastinated on A5 I mean there was no
better version than that
and all of a sudden there aren't that
many
many uh Avenues you can open here at
this point you have to go B6 at some
point
we've been here before don't repeat
three times
okay he's gonna use his King to prepare
it
wow
that's risky I mean I don't think you
can play B6 here I'm I'm afraid takes in
Rook A1
yeah with Queen A2 ideas coming
ah this is not simple oh he said ah oh
and Rook H3 you found the way
yeah okay it's winning you gotta try it
if your knee-hole though you gotta take
that Bishop
yep
he's gonna get mated there's just no way
to survive yeah Rook of three even Queen
F3
I'm trying to set up some sort of five I
don't see it
yeah Queen E3 almost stalemate but you
have the F1 Square you gotta find Queen
E3 Miss wait a second when they cheat
oh wait still Queenie one still Queenie
one I'm in disbelief it's a draw
yeah he might still be winning here
Queen F4 Queen F4
oh
careful yeah don't repeat which Pawn is
he gonna take I would take on F4 and
then take on D4 he's trying to force it
with Chuck but he's got to be so careful
not to repeat move yeah yeah Queen F3 no
I mean wasn't queen of four there
what's he worried about like you're
never at risk
zero risk you can repeat with Perpetual
at literally any time
that is oh my goodness mind-boggling he
was literally down a piece and getting
checkmated
and he's still true kidding me
no but that's just such a confidence
Buster on top of the objective damage
that you do when you miss a win like
this the lead remains three
and
the lead was three before the bullet
segment of the aronian and dracon mess
Jeffrey but
this just feels different it feels
different it's it's a whole other story
with Neo involved especially just
considering all of those games which
we've seen
and yeah it's a it's a tough tough climb
it's gonna be a very tough climb indeed
he's gonna have 30 minutes to climb this
particular mountain and he's gonna have
to start the comeback early he can't
afford to lose the first couple of games
it's gonna be crazy don't go anywhere
now before we go on a break and get set
up for the bullet make sure to get ready
for the December 2022 stateofchess.com
yes it's back coming to you live on
December 21st we have some huge news for
the chess community and the event will
be followed by a Community Q a plus it's
a very special guest will be joining the
show to talk about the exciting
announcement and what it means for the
future of Chess and the chess Community
don't miss the show mark your calendar
is December 21st at 10 A.M Pacific 1 pm
Eastern Time right here on twitch.tv
slash chess state of Chess coming your
way soon but the bullet segment is
coming your way right on the other side
of this break here at the speed Chess
Championship stay tuned
foreign
use gifts not GIFs from the biggest
chest stars on all of your favorite
platforms just search chess.com and your
favorite chess star on Discord Twitter
WhatsApp and more to find hundreds of
gifts from chess.com's biggest
broadcasts and events pokemane Ludwig
voice critical xqc and even me Danny try
it today
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the speed Chess
Championship the match between Niall
Sarah and Anish Gary has taken so many
turns chopping enough for you GM Daniel
nerdinski alongside Grand Master Jeffrey
Jean the winner of yesterday's title
Tuesday it's been a pleasure covering
the match with you so far Jeffrey let's
remind everybody of what's at stake
prize wise we've got a twenty thousand
dollar purse for uh the finals and you
can see the layout there just some
awesome prizes Jeffrey as if people
needed any more motivation to watch the
SCC
foreign
yeah right now for everyone it's all
about survive in advance look at that
lovely increase as you move on the
prices just get so heavy and right now I
just want to see canonish muster himself
can he regain his composure because
those last two games
were heartbreaking for him I mean he
could have had this mesh tied I think uh
a few games ago easily and now it's a
three-point Gap heading into bullet yeah
it just seems like every knee-high star
and match involves so many of these
ridiculous Houdini acts but as Robert
Hess likes to point out sometimes
players who aren't necessarily known for
their bullet skill that they're able to
muster up a surprising amount of speed
in the bullet segment we saw that once
again with Levon aronian who I think
anishagiri has to look up to right now
for some inspiration here we go a
Queen's Gambit accepted once more in
game one and so far so good for Anis she
has more time than he started with and
he's got some pressure going in the
center
yeah quick Bishop three intending to
bring this Knight into C6 carve out that
square 95 D5 could lead to issues so
Neil gonna try and keep the tension in
your queen C7
okay so we might get a mass trade D7 B7
Anish taking the first
significant think of the game
and you only have one of these because
he's not only down to 40 seconds
and boy yeah I mean he's trying to see
how not to simplify the situation like
so often Queen's gamut accepted
once things get swapped off it's just uh
dead even so I don't know how is he
planning to create chances
I don't think he is I think he's just
trading everything but the position
maybe a smidge better for white I like
the placement of the bishop on B2 he's
like what Bishop on B2 it's now been
traded for the Knight
the position almost resembles a
Rubenstein French
yes I was gonna say you could even
consider leaving your king in the middle
there and try to play along the G file
but this is a very safe approach
just gonna double in even though you've
got the double F pawns they can't really
be targeted
and at this point you're already
basically starting to play the clock if
you're knee-hole you want to drag these
games out we've seen some bullet games
take upwards of four minutes
and this looks like it could be one of
those games that could feature a long
grinded out end game exactly what nehal
wants as he sits on this three-point
lead
right as a niche how do you sort of at
the very least maybe you just want to
you just want to trade Rooks here and
and like uh invade along the light
squares the week B5 yeah I thought Neil
might have rushed that Queen trade I
didn't think there was any need
s off the board he he was a little over
eager there now the knight's getting to
D3 and White's starting to make some
serious progress
do you trade Rooks here yes and he's
gonna go A4 and bring the king in he's
gonna try to bring the king in
immediately but that gives the option of
B5 which nehal might want to exploit
yeah this has to be winning for white at
this point or very close to winning
yes once the king lands on B5 you get
the Knight on C4 he has to capitalize
Knight B2 he's just winning a pawn now
and basically the game because King B7
Knight D6 okay he drops the pawn
and there goes the other one just F3
four all the pawns are on light squares
wow
well well well another twist
what haven't we seen yeah
well I mean that was uh basically a out
of the blue I thought you know I had
everything under wraps but
just ended up being a white wash yeah
the decision to trade Queens I think
that was the ultimate culprit and guess
what this is exactly how the aronian and
draken bullet segment started he wins
one more game and it's a one-point match
so I actually think this one's really
pivotal as they have yet another Believe
It or Not jababa London
but I really like this version because
he can play ed4 or E4 but essentially
followed it up with F5 opening the
bishop suddenly F4 is a big idea
and in a bullet game it's all about not
just the objective eval but you know who
has the easier game practically and here
black can just rattle off a lot of these
moves Bishop D7 rookie eight you got a
pretty easy pawn storm on the queen side
on the other hand White's got G4 G6
ah G4 an important idea to
take into account goes Knight D4 first
now he's gonna go G4 oh and Anish might
have overlooked that
is there something after G4
can you go like Bishop G7 no but just
Queen H
even something I mean two yeah Queen H
fill in the blank
both nibs look promising at least Queen
H3 maybe there's FG so Queen is slightly
more precise now can he get away with
this I think he can these pawns are
actually very good defensive pieces and
the King has a a beautiful parking spot
on F7
black is better
30 seconds up
you don't see the Triple G puns like
that every day
yeah that's nuts and F2 is hanging at
the same time
big problem for me Hulk in G3 maybe
Queen D7 just try to keep these pawns
alive as long as possible
oh I have three I think you just ignore
it though you don't don't touch it no no
no okay yeah we're just
A4 makes sense
maybe A3
and you don't want to rush C5 because
then you weaken the D5 Pawn I like his
decision to go B5 and definitely trading
no but now
six I'm not sure
he gets rid of the Knight now obviously
that is a concession but black
definitely the one still in the driver's
seat 96 is coming in
Rook F2 Knight C5 I mean lots of
improving moves here
and look at the time disparity no this
is this has been phenomenal time
management 94
. he's playing like in an inveterate
bullet player I mean this has been crazy
so far in the bullet segment
can he capitalize huge huge chance here
for a niche he's milking the position
maybe Knight of six now he checks don't
repeat can't give up half a point this
is a golden opportunity E4 though oh
I can't believe Neo can get away with it
so that D4 Rook D but there was nothing
wait dude
oh he walked right into me Rook T5 is
made
in one
Rook d8 was also made in my
mind
oh my gosh a win in this game ties the
match here we go again
I mean Bobby called it I gotta give him
credit where it's dude
I thought this is going to be a runaway
but
Anish showing like was up 20 to 30
seconds in that game
yeah and that might be just as
impressive as the results themselves his
time management has been unbelievable
and he's not playing too fast either
he's taking his time at the right
moments
but the good news for nehals he's still
a point up and I don't think his
confidence has been shaken he all
doesn't get too high with the highs but
he also doesn't get too low with the
lows and I think he's Gonna Keep
try to keep his foot on the gas pedal
here and come back with a big victory in
this game of the black pieces
you most certainly will but
all right and he's taking his time here
I like the the looks of D5 just
take space and and put a knight on C4
aha
kind of benoni style especially now it
comes with tempo
wait up okay six hangs but I guess E4
yeah
it's gonna do it
yeah there's no Bishop B5 you would be
trapped whoa he sacks the full piece I
mean niho nihal doesn't want to draw
here he wants to recover with a victory
in this game
looks like a brilliant practical
decision maybe just a great decision in
general what he has to be so careful
about is not losing A6 at some point and
allowing this Apon forward but he's
that's not a problem anymore he can take
A5 on demand
yeah he's already got three pawns he can
collect another one don't like Bishop F6
perhaps yeah running out of steam here
94 comes with a Tempo now and suddenly
White's kind of in charge Bishop C4
Bishop C4 looks really imposing
huh so what is the count here four pawns
for a piece white has both Bishops very
funny material imbalance that Bishop on
H6 is kind of a bone in Black's throat
and Neal is going to try to make
something of that
But Here Comes The Pawn
oh this is gonna get you super spicy
slowly crafting ideas on the king's side
now Queen C3 is an option to provoke
more weaknesses and maybe go G5 at the
right moment
yeah there's no A3
D4 35
B4 E4 oh what's his idea we have three
and Bishop should see beautiful four
yeah he's got an E6 Queen F6 that would
be huge so if you go for the end game
here probably not not in a bullet game I
think practically you have to try to
keep the Queens
and maybe even repeat moves I wouldn't
mind a repetition if I'm a niche
uh
I don't know I feel like he's got to
take his chances here I mean I know that
it's he's already gotten okay three okay
three
he doesn't see it though will he find
Rook takes A3 wins the game
oh I missed it gonna move all right G3
once Bishop G2 it's that's still a
pretty nasty little move there
now Rook A3 is still in there 85. now
Neil but Bishop Queen E55
oh that is nasty
this is insane he's won three in a row
a hat trick and the match is leveled
unbelievable
and just try that on for size the first
three-game winning streak of this match
for Anish comes in the bullet
and the match ladies and gentlemen is
tied
at 10 a piece
an afternoon it's better again
Knight C3 Knight fd5 oh I need a
knee-haul is totally reeling here
Knight C3 Knight C5 the bishop hangs at
the end of the line
it does feel like this can start going
the other way he's I mean niho's slowly
unraveling I don't see a good way to
deal with this and neither does nino he
has to give up the e-born at least he
gets Black's Bishop in return good
decision there
great decision right some compensation
here
um
in the means of Black's backward E Pawn
I would just go Queen B6 knock the queen
out of D4
this looks really bad for white all of a
sudden with that E5 Square belonging to
Black's night
yeah Rook C8 you can put this in a
variety of ways I think you just stick
the Knight on E5 though
and Rook D1 is a sad necessity because
otherwise there were tactics with Rook
C3 and Knight D5
oh yeah and queen B4 I love Queen B4
and you should say forcing Queens off
infiltrating right now Queen B4 is a
great move Queen B4 I love this
taking some time
but he better see Queen B4 I think he's
still okay like even if G5 comes what's
the big deal you go Knight fd7 I guess
we mean he's gonna prepare but Rook D4
oh there is Rook D4 which I forgot about
yeah but I love rookie J as well
anticipating the h-file opening and
maybe Black's the one that's uh the more
ready for for such a transition and if
you have to play a move like Knight E2
that is not a good sign maybe even a
sack on E5
practically speakers that's what he has
in mind but rooksy too
wait now what exactly is this can I take
on A2 and he says thank you for the pawn
where's your attack
Rock Solid everything defended
unbelievable F6 is protected
I would just go yeah now he plays Queen
before to pin the bishop holy smokes
wise piece is completely stuck another
great move
and every move is better than the last
one so far
but it can all change at the drop of a
hat
I mean white
I just can't do anything like rookstem
met with Queen E1 exactly he's losing B3
no hesitation there Queen he won even
now is possible
there it is yeah Queenie one he spots it
I'm speechless my
goodness barring
craziness in this game that's a great
move by nehal though
still three pawns at the end of the day
yeah Rook H2 would be a crazy idea
taking advantage with Knight G4 uh maybe
A3 but
into that a pawn somehow
but he can't he can't no I think even
the end game Knight C5 just Knights
fight with the fork or this rookie eight
is such a composed mature move
boom
what are we witnessing Knight D2 Knight
P3 but wait the hall goes back to D4
it's still not over
maybe just collect another Pawn then
while you're at it take on G5 and notice
how many practical decisions Anisha is
making he's playing this like a habitual
bullet player
yeah he knows that he should be able to
convert this without too many
difficulties and milk a good amount of
time off the match clock which is now
down to 16 minutes
and he should be able to convert
although 98 he got four threatening made
it once almost oh my God oh my God okay
there was a maiden one threat for white
only nehal can do that
he's having a hard time
but this isn't bad I really I really
think he will convert this and take the
time off the clock by the way not I mean
Jeffrey there was a tactic with Knight
D3 and Knight takes E4 using that Bishop
on A4 ah with the fourth bait yeah
okay he finally makes some progress King
G5 blunder z7
ig7 another clinical move and F5 might
be coming next
whoa oh he takes which I'm not sure
about that move
still all right though nice blockade
here yeah you don't even need to play
Knight C7 the knight's just perfectly
placed on E8 and Yeehaw resigns and you
were absolutely right
oh
sheesh it's got the lead I I think it's
first lead since that like the the Run
earlier on when he was up 3-1 and can
nehal figure out how to bounce back from
this Abby's like sipping on his smoothie
somewhere with an I Told You So
impression on his face and smarter chess
predicts at this point a higher
probability of a Geary Victory and given
the momentum I don't disagree with it
he's better again
niho trying to get some kind of Play
Bishop G4 Rook d8 D4 if it's soft can
you take it play g696 next
yeah knee-hole kind of accelerating his
Pace here trying a different game
strategy as he drags his Knight over to
F5 this could get dangerous for white in
a bullet game it's very double-edged
I mean back to this Merchants though it
was 14 for any going into the bullet and
I would have actually argued putting it
lower based on what we saw but
this is it's an insane turn event I
don't know what words can't even
describe I think the lesson regardless
of the results of this match is that you
just cannot make any conclusions about
people's bullet strengths especially
given that it's one plus one and as
we've discussed totally different game
from 100
Queen's three here 94 would be a massive
idea Knight can jump into F6 or D6 I
guess problematic again probably black
will meet that with Knight F5 but I
agree
he stops 94 good move by wait a second
no Rook F7 has to be good for white
doesn't it
I mean I understand you win D4 maybe
these are the kind of complications
Neil's trying I don't know though
because Rook D4 you just tried and mop
up the seventh rank pawns Knight takes
D4 you go Rook Dita F1 and black can't
move the Rooks away from the back rank
whoa he's six oh but how about E6 this
is also very strong maybe even stronger
I guess C5 C5 you have to solidify that
Knight on D4 if you're yeah E7 would be
a threat if not E7 and Rook D4 with back
rink ideas he just takes in he says come
at me bro
and where is The Knockout maybe just
Rook takes B7 maybe nothing better than
Rook B7 and you gotta play quickly if
you're a niche
and move the Rook away
another brilliant proflexus wow stopping
92 check making sure that anytime the
Knight moves you have the time to
deliver made on G7
Rook F1 yeah Rook F1 is a nice Tempo I'm
getting worried about anisha's clock
this is the first time nihal has managed
to bring and bring is there oh rookie
three Quincy yeah Rook through Queen C4
check is important and now Knight F1
wreckage three though no rookie two he
blundered no Queenie two No No rookie
two oh my God
so where's the move oh my God
what is this just but I think it's a 24
and Knight F3
but there's always the hanging at the
end you're exactly right and I missed
that Rook takes the eight is a back
ranker
what a game wow
and the first game nihal has not lost in
19 minutes of bullet
oh and he might have been fortunate
there like he was in trouble could have
been five in a row for a niche potential
I would have just taken on E2 and lost
on the spot I don't know how nehal
managed to navigate those complications
okay still a one point lead
yeah this it's and it's an insane gear
that Anish has has kicked in and then
saying what Gary oh
[Laughter]
you've got to pull down the low hanging
fruit low any fruit yeah I mean the long
hanging fruit you have to grab okay so
what do we have here a jababa London big
surprise first time in the match
but Neal having a hard time castling
maybe you've got to go Knight ab1 here
oh F3 I'm not sure about that E3 Pawn
okay but the good thing for white is
that Bishop takes A6 is now a serious
positional threat and night before there
was Bishop D6 so I like Knight B8 love
Knight B8
indeed that was a key tactic there with
Bishop D6
97 got it like Carl's bad but can Wego
B5 here
well he does and maybe A6 was worth it
Bishop f8 was his potential idea holy
smokes he's sharp and C5 Maybe
now I like c58
yeah yeah maybe C5 he would take a
knight D4 so you don't have to rush with
that and he does but he
hard to evaluate this position because
why does this big weakness on E3 we've
had these middle games before with
colors reversed
yeah I like Rook C8 here and then
followed by 95.
I mean Foursquare
for black yeah like Rook seat
God Anisha seems so in control of
everything Bishop D4
was that working oh my God it was
because the E2 was saying in the end a
big Miss there that didn't win a piece
but it did win a big Pawn
yes
but still I mean this position
so hard for white to really penetrate
and I think black is the one with the
ideas
and Black's the one with the squares
God and I'd see four coming in
okay here comes the passport has to give
it up and if you play C3 too quickly
that pawn could turn into a weakness so
I actually like probably go Rook C4 yeah
Rook C4 is nice
nine and a half in the match so still
plenty of time for again for games this
shift to be played Bishop D5 here
you can always simplify if you he bails
out immediately but I think anisha's
still the one playing for a win here yes
absolutely his F4 Bishop E4 King B3
I wouldn't do anything too crazy if
you're on each just trade Rooks to make
the drop three yeah wait oh I thought he
blundered a holy crap maybe he did
yes Rook a two check winning black
White's Bishop
unbelievable I don't like the decision
for Anish to go for this Jeffrey because
the kids
Super Active too
I'm taking D5 I think nihal can take
this one he goes B6 big decision there
he could end up losing that pawn
and he will
Rook F6 I'm gonna give it up oh Rook of
sits would uncut the king but maybe the
pawn end game was lost after takes in
King D6 why was promoting with check
there oh unbelievable tactics here
would be winning for white
oh D7 three no don't go D7 you were
losing your queen there
oh with rookies Rook D3 I mean this is
crazy
it's still not over
I guess the a pawn is too far away but
it's gonna keep checking him yeah but
how do you actually make the winning
Progressive
oh my God I slide to E8 yeah slide to E8
oh or is this not the way I guess not
maybe A2 should have been thrown in by a
niche
oh he's gonna give up what is going on
Brooke but no this is lost ah ks3 G5 yes
it's over oh my God it's a tie match
again oh so Topsy Terry that one
could not even process a single thing
and Jeffrey I think ultimately the
culprit can be traced back to his
decision to not trade Rooks with a one
point lead on the black thesis he had to
play more conservatively there can't
fault him from taking the gutsy call
though
through a bold decision there that might
be something we talk about after the
match but we're tied here nearing seven
minutes
sharp opening choice now from nehal is
playing his beloved perk yeah he's going
for the win here he might even take back
with a pawn he doesn't necessarily mind
that end game I don't know the knight's
coming to D5 though pretty quickly there
I like D5 so yeah you go Knight to five
I put my knight on D4 and I kick your
knight out objectively black is
definitely worse than these types of
positions Bishop P2 F4 and then quickly
maybe H4 H5 can be considered oh and
he's playing for the mate here
H5 yes I like H5
why not this is a terrible position for
black he hasn't put his clothes on on
the queen side and he's already getting
mated
that is a funny way of putting it yeah I
think oh B5 desperation he just put his
clothes on
so F4 Knight C4 and if Knight B5 I guess
he's just going Rook B8 what a practical
decision by niho okay so B4 Bishop G7 is
curtains
I would I would throw in Knight takes B5
just to eliminate that way
I was calculating like a bishop of Fate
there Bishops Bishop h8 Bishop f8 with
the idea that sack on h8 Queen H6 oh
that's beautiful on Rook H1 in the end
Anish playing it
more simply with F4 he's just using that
pin against the Knight on F6
this has to be winning no
this is uh after nights before I think
you just take you have a multitude of
ways to take advantage of the pin I
think here now oh fe5 BC and 94 tricky
knee-hole and Knight D5 still 94.
no he goes back to D7 simply he keeps
the tension look at this too much was
hanging in the line maybe just after
three oh yeah watch the clock here
Bishop three keep it simple
C6 is not a move I guess it's D60 thing
it's been winning for like years but
Anish hasn't actually made the decisive
progress as he tries to double on the H
file that's a big idea Bishop E2 Rook
double
what's he got oh yeah Rook h8 Rook H7
it's a main thread you gotta move though
king of Fate I guess he wants to escape
he's gonna make a run for it and he's
still alive
but F4 is coming
F4 is coming and it's coming at the
least opportune moment it's going to
send the Knight back to D7 and F7 should
fall there
yeah Bishop C4 you have all sorts of
ideas
F4 Now's the Time
Bishop C4
two seconds four is huge
maybe just sack on F7 at some point
there's no actual tactic unfortunately
so he's got it
around he's gonna drop the bishop
panicking oh God can he sack still F5
just throw everything into the fire no
there's back rink problems or queen H2
yeah King E6 Queen H2 threatens me
Queen H2O and queen G2 how do you get
out oh my God how do you threaten yeah
Queen G4 is a main threat there's no
defense it's me
just win The Rook
and and just trade Queens okay
whatever you do yeah okay
Rook H1 is nice
take it and go G6 it's over G6 wow
holy smokes
I Niche Back on Top by a point three
minutes 50 seconds left
and now it's suddenly knee-haw on the
brink if he loses this game that's the
match and he has to know that at this
point yeah if he loses I would say in
over two minutes that is basically the
match but he's got the white pieces he's
playing his pet jababa he knows these
positions really well I like this choice
and they're repeating the line from the
Blitz game
like where Anish got his attack going
with F4
okay rookie one we've had very similar
position
in that game somehow
yeah I thought he could do the same
thing there
now c4
so this time nihal chipping away at the
center but he's in so much Danger on the
king side here
yeah you take on D5 I think and maybe go
Queen now
yeah they're see there feels like I mean
it feels loosey-goosey all around for
black it most certainly does Anish going
for the kill the bishop sack
oh that's a great move his GH massive
moment you collect all the puns
you do and then your queen comes in but
how do you navigate the complications
here Queen B3 is a great practical move
and he played it fast
yeah those bullet instincts kicking in
for knee-hole Knight C7
also a massive threat hitting everything
and if Knight takes F3 Bishop F3 you
don't have Knight D2 because again that
very weak Pawn on D5 just hangs 25
seconds for me for Anish I don't think
he sees a move
well pointed out yeah I'm trying to see
how do I keep the tech going but there's
no clear way and Knight C7 here oh and
look at the speed Rook ac1 just stepping
on the gas pedal here banking on trying
to flag him basically
at E6 covering the square G5 G4 very
dangerous idea by the way that could
lead to me
uh what do you do Bishop D3 or do you
take
okay Rook F7 is there now can I take a
knight D6 oh it's so hard to calculate I
think you can and I think he's got to go
for it quickly just hope that Anish
doesn't have enough time for the
complications
he had Knight C5
oh geez no I'd see 500 have been winning
for black
now seven
and I go like mystery 795 with Tempo I
feel like there are too many
infiltration spots and now Queen takes
D5 picks up
but still Rook d8 oh yeah maybe 95 was
hasty
oh my God he plays it anyway
this is a must
it is yeah is there like a knight G6 I'm
wondering or a knight's oh yeah Knight
takes G6 picks up a pawn
a draw is satisfactory for me and gives
him another chance I think it's an even
end game you take and take on D5 Jeffrey
he's got to pay attention to the clock
because if he gets down to a draw
then he has to hit the game before the
match is over
he could yeah but he loses a pawn
okay now he's got to win this end game
that's it this is gonna be the last game
wait okay five Rook D1 rookie two fifty
one Rook D2 oh my gosh and with the
increment Anish has a chance to save
this
F3
he's winning
oh my God
well wait a second though G4 G3 this is
so tricky it is tricky maybe
move and no chapter three is huge if
black gets the king to H5 the pawn on G4
is gonna be pinned
20 seconds left on the match clock oh my
God
wait we can't I don't know how do you
repeat can you and G4 is a massive
threat here oh my gosh
Rook A3
and G4 gotta go back yes
G1 and you want G3 this is okay two Rook
a two
we're okay two played he has F3 he has
G3
do you think you can just repeat moves
oh okay this also works yeah this way it
works but Neal's gonna try A6 and Rook
A5 oh my God I think he's gonna win
oh no
oh my God it's winning now King F4
oh
my god king F5 he's gonna go he's
winning oh that's it now he's officially
winning oh my gosh
holy oh we're gonna we're gonna get a
time wait not quite yet but he has too
many Pawns
yeah King G6 cut off the king and push
that F Pawn it's over oh my God
he found a way
I think the best thing in such a
situation is not to say anything
like that's that's the most effective
way to just explain what just happened
you found the very last trick
folks oh my God
we are going to another tie break we've
got more chess to play now very quickly
very important the format is simple
that's the four games so first to two
and a half wins if the score at the end
of the four games is 2-2 then they go to
an arm again there will be a bidding
process we will explain that if they
ultimately go for Armageddon but right
now we've got four more games of one
plus one and we are not going on a break
so do not go anywhere
oh my God
can you believe me so you're saying
no I absolutely can't but you're saying
that the games are gonna start
immediately the games are gonna start
immediately no break
wow I mean I wanted to saying to catch
my breath but here we go I guess
yeah it was Destiny and when Anish was
repeating with Rook A1 and Rook B1 and
Rook B2
Jeffrey as soon as I saw the king's
Pathway to D3 and that idea of going A6
that's when I could sense that Anish was
going to lose the thread
yeah because it turned out those f and g
points were just one tempo too slow in
all those lines
I mean it just totally defies belief but
Anish he has to push this behind him he
has to celebrate the fact that he
managed to get this to a tied match he
was leading for most of the bullet and
if he plays the same way he's played
with the same level of confidence I
think he's got a very good shot
yeah he did not seem to be any worse
than the bullet in fact he was the much
better bullet player in that segment
hands down just with the time spending
and that intuition
this is following a very similar script
to to Don draken matches in it and in
the draken match they went back and
forth in the bullet up until the last
game when Dimitri on draken
swindled a lost position into a winning
position only to blunder at the end so
Levon aronian got the better of him in
the tiebreaker it is all nerves Jeffrey
literally the players are just all
nerves right now
yeah I personally I think I've I've had
two tie breaks one against uh
I believe it was way ye in the final one
against
uh gladora and the moment the Ty break
starts my heart was pumping no it's I I
cannot imagine what the players are
feeling right now both of them and here
we go Anish has the white pieces in the
first tiebreaker game once again four
games of one plus one first to two and a
half wins and nihal he has opted for
this beloved modern every time he hasn't
gotten good positions thus far Jeffrey
but this time he doesn't Rush E5
yeah but still I think h4h5 is going to
be
on tap immediately for a niche I just
don't know if he wants to even waste
time developing the bishop first no he
just goes right ahead and I would still
take on E5 now maybe this time knee Hall
is going to take back with a pawn and
offer the queen trade which has to be
correct yeah Queen maybe Queenie one
keep the Queens on the board at all
costs
no perhaps yeah the end game
doesn't look too bad for blacklight
maybe you'd take a knight D4
he goes Knight D4 immediately now H5
looks Modi Mada dangerous
H5 and okay you know obser F4 instead so
if you go Knight G4 F takes E5 and the
Knight loses its support again this
could get very bad for black
yeah that's messy maybe you have like
Knight F3 there 94 Fe no knife through
Queen E2 would be a nasty double attack
are you sure that's not Ronaldo after
Queen takes E3 F4 and E5
oh gosh this looks totally no E5 Knight
F5 E5 there was five oh still tricks but
Gary knows what to focus on
This Modern has to go into the trash can
Ernie Hall it does I mean this is just
disaster ferocious
E5 or queen H3 Knight E4 also but he had
a hard time checkmating nehal the last
time he had this h-file attack can he
deliver more smoothly this time
I think he can that is true that is true
it came down to uh like just uh your
seconds no seven is that Knight D6
following up
he's he's seven Quidditch
it's not totally clean yeah this doesn't
look clear-cut to Me Maybe C3
but that allows 92 takes F4 I'm not
totally sure about that
rookie six and somehow nihal is holding
on and maybe even Rook takes D6 he's
better
oh my lands oh I'm doing it again
is there F5 knee-haul will the Gary with
a full send on the king side Rook hg1
still not over
rookie Queen F6 just C3 yeah it's just
one threat well the threat is Rook takes
F5 as well as of course Rook takes G6 I
don't see a defense here
should be fine
Queen takes G6
you have checks but they don't amount to
anything maybe Queen E3 Queen H6
oh getting the Queens off the board but
Queen G6 in that I think this is over
he's got a couple of checks but not more
than that King A1 that's it Queen G7 g17
g17 yep and it makes no sense for any
Hall to resign well now it does
but in general there's no ticker so like
you can prolong these games as long as
possible there's no downside and Anish
giri strikes again
well I mean that one
was on its hinge but Anish came away
with it and
pressure right back on niho to strike
back and the most impressive thing about
that might have been the way he
recovered after blundering initially
because we thought it was over nehal
found a way to get two pieces for a rook
but Anish Gary did not let up and he
pushed F5 at the right moment okay we
have this closed Center King's Indian
attack position
I always like these for black and a
bullet in a bullet game
me too I've always thought the king side
attack trumps the queen set attack and
bullet totally agreed
so that's we're gonna try ah maybe he's
got okay I was gonna say queen Sim Queen
before but C5 Queen A6 still but this is
a this is a tremendously risky approach
for white because his entire Center is
now Under Fire and queen D6 there's
Bishop back to f8 yes and then the D4
Park Falls at the end oh
this is very problematic maybe ah Knight
B3 there's Knight F4 potentially or like
an H3 thrown in
yeah niho could lose control here at the
drop of a hat he might have already lost
control after Knight takes D4 and E3 uh
could be E3 okay Knight F1 I like a lot
stopping any E3 you get I mean you try
and simplify things here maybe take some
Bishop G4 but then Rook takes D6 on pins
with tempo
okay Gary with a practical move
I like to just take and play Yesterday
ah again Bishop G4 I need to worry about
so I would play Bishop D6 Bishop G4 and
then maybe just like rookie one it's not
glamorous but if you can bring
everything together you'll have that
past C Pawn
oh but I like this move you stop this
before you stop H3 if you can consult it
the position with 93 and regain the pawn
you could return things around slowly
Bishop E6 93 Bishop H6 he goes D5 I
thought about that but I didn't see a
follow-up after Bishop C1
maybe once Bishop B fire Bishop A4 nehal
wants the same move on the other side
Bishop G5 go after the H Pawn
uh-huh so Bishop G5 Rook C2
I feel like Black's activity has to be
enough at the very least for equality
but probably for more than that
but I love this Knight on E3 Knight T5
no don't do that there was a fork on E7
oh
easy to miss
okay the Knight comes to D3 watch out
but the d-pump bishop B7 and D6 were
Knight D5 oh
oh this is huge Knight D5 we're
can also bring the rook in
now what must have the upper hand
wait does white have a way to keep them
on 97 Knight C6 and rookie seven
oh my and D7 if you take oh nice if you
take oh he just keeps the tension but he
gives up the pawn
okay now Gary should stabilize
oh we blundered ip8 and now he's gonna
give up the pawn
yes he's gonna he's gonna win a sixth
note he escapes through H7
I think Gary's okay Gary should be fine
here yeah and now move that damn night
away
still it is a pawn up we've seen Yeehaw
win we've seen these Pawn end games
earlier we've seen him win a pond down
in this position 96 Fork threat
oh my God how many of these says Gary
had to defend against nehal in this
match keep the knights yeah just
countless keep the knights try to get
your knight to E5 try to find a fork
torture him forever
if you're any if you're knee-haul Knight
D6 is already scary extremely with seven
seconds left I don't think he's holding
this one
he's down to zero seconds he's gonna
flag doesn't see a move and I didn't see
one either I didn't see one either there
might have been some crazy computer
defense nehal ties it again and he flies
a modern again
oh my God this is crazy
okay at least he's not gonna get mated
this time and these cast was kingside
but
yeah no this this I can absolutely get
behind because nihal likes the king's
Indian setup with black and with same
side castling I like his position
okay but that's a big move hexa d4 is a
surprise whoa I don't like that Knight
C4 looks really nasty at some point
right rooksy won a very useful move
now can Neo really get away with this
doesn't seem that way but in a bullet
game anything is possible Gary hits him
where it hurts on that D6 Pawn
no this is
they'll play Queen B6 E5 Knight D5 but
even then d e and Knight D5 and Bishop
B7 somehow
but you dropped the bishop back and you
go 94. yeah the moment the Knight lands
on D6 white could end up just being
completely winning
and look at the clock unbelievable
Geary's of 20 seconds
I'm calculating
so Bishop 195 what's going on there
well I think that's what Gary's trying
to determine as well
wait 95 just might be good for black
yeah I thought I had some tactic here
but
can't make anything worse oh I think he
doesn't see it either
so now hang on I could just take in C3
for example Rook data is also attractive
and maybe if you're white you just bite
the bullet trade everything and try to
take on C4 try to get away with it using
some Knight F6 related tactics I don't
see it though
still a game a queen of three Rook e to
D1 get that Rook wait a minute if I take
twice F5 oh there's F5
which is why I think white has to move
the Rook away a sad necessity
wait
kg7
but again what if I take I think still
F5 and rookie one
same answer okay wait 93 93 ends it
93. oh there's just a discovery on the
queen
Gary lost track of the main threat
oh my God he's gonna have a must-win
game with the black pieces
wanted rookie one
wow
turning on a swivel
oh my God he loses the bishop on B1 he's
gonna resign
and he will have to win the next game to
force Armageddon but with black he's had
a hard time generating winning chances
on demand
oh
don't go Queen F6 G5 still not over
maybe I guess Rook B5 is is a move you
control d8 Square critical after Queen
F2 black gets mated
F4 still trying wait a second oh yeah
and King h8 officially no checks Rook H5
no mate on f8
and Gary resigns and here we go
it all comes down to this
yeah on demand necessary for a niche but
geez Niha just he always finds a way to
he's just Relentless it's crazy and if
you're knee-hole you don't try to force
a draw you play the way you normally
would and if you have an opportunity to
liquidate to an equal end game you do it
same goes for a niche you don't want to
do anything crazy you just play the
position and pounce on your opportunity
I like this opening Choice by a niche
it's a good compromise
I do as well yeah this is bull at the
end of the day even the driest positions
can
feature something at at a mo at a
moment's notice but the Knight tries to
come into C4 Anish says no such luck and
I like that trade from Black's
perspective the King on F1 is a little
bit loosey-goosey
what about planning a bishop B4 yes
totally no I like Black's position here
from a bullet perspective okay the
Knight comes to C5 he wants 96 Knight D4
which is a classic King's Indian
maneuver
and he does it
Pleasant here I want to say for Anisha
although how do you proceed now this
decision to put the queen on C4 is huge
because it stops Bishop B4
and with every trade it becomes harder
and harder to oh he bows slips
um
oh and look at a niche oh no that's you
sorry
and I think nihal is actually trying to
figure out a way to keep the extra piece
which is not easy to do
yeah which is not easy to do he's gonna
win it back
I guess not the worst slip of all time
but I have to remember like Knight C3
here
the problem is that you need to win it's
gonna be exactly if he manages to win
this I am going to lose my ever loving
mind I already have
okay nihal has to move though you don't
want this coming down to a Time scramble
right you don't want to take any chances
with the clock running
I don't like that move Knight comes back
to C5 and now E4 is a chance
which he missed this one feels a bit
passive
I go like 96 now yep he's 694 simplify
the first step for Anish is to make sure
he doesn't lose any more pieces and then
try to go E4 at the right moment wait he
wins the pawn back on B2 oh my God
no but it's how is he gonna win much
yeah can you get away with Knight G5
Rook C4 rookie eight
oh wait that's why he goes Knight D4
he's down to six seconds anything can
happen
oh that's a great move five is that's a
phenomenal move
and C3 next if you're a niche keep the
Rooks on the board go H5 and just wait
for a blunder
yeah you have I mean the clock is your
only hope literally and Anything Could
Happen Anish his hands are knee-haw's
hands are shaking we know Anisha Sands
are shaking he Mouse slipped
G4 that's a huge solution
four maybe Rook a two Rook a two attacks
the pawn on B2 and you can't go back to
E2 yes you would have to go Rook B1 in
that case oh he throws he's trying to
muddy the waters with a check on F4 but
he's gotta go through seconds
Rook G5 Mass 93 93 oh my God no we
missed it oh
wait there's a mate thread on H1 still
Knight H3 Knight H3 Knight H3 and take
F2 Oh anisha's missing everything but
he's trying to get his work to h8 rookie
J key F1 oh my God it's still not made
he's exhausted all the ideas now I don't
see
somebody's attacking
Rook C3 doesn't work
maybe Knight D5 just go back take B4
keep it going
oh but knee-haul stabilized now he's
Consolidated yeah he's totally
Consolidated and now he's better Knight
F5 Knight D6
no he goes back
don't like that move
there's still chances oh absolutely go
Rook C8 Rook d8 something
Knight F4
Force the trade Rook C3 though he's
gonna win the ball G4 hang on Richie for
no he gives it to him no take the pawn
he had King D3
and niho won a very similar End Game On
Demand against Anish in the cgc can he
return the favor
what a moment this is 2V1 really it's
wrong for under seconds
well Jeffrey correct me if I'm wrong
Black's only winning idea here or
winning attempt is at some point to play
like F4 and F3 obviously this is a draw
objectively obviously
but if Neo Keeps The Rook on the G file
I think there's no way to achieve that
what about getting the king to F4 and
playing Rook B2 to threaten G3 well
still I'm waiting I go Rook G8 oh he's
Gonna Keep The Rook on the f o another
idea I don't know but now F4 is coming
and this is how I've seen people lose
this allowing up for F4 I give a bunch
of checks gotta try it he's got a flag
oh my gosh I think Neo's displaying the
right technique he is and Anisha has to
build up a little time and play out for
he has to try F4
Rook D5 I like but King G3 there's gonna
be a three-time repetition if he's not
careful
go F4 now what if I gave checks
yeah you zigzag your way
rugby two
F3
gotta try up three
you got it he does
camski try F3
wait Rook C1 Rook F1 that's the idea
maybe you can hold it on the on the
second ring but the King goes around oh
but also this no also this yeah this is
a draw yeah Rook G5 Rook H5 that's it
that's basically it
oh my God he's gonna hold it oh
every time it feels like every time he
he just finds a way to clutch
I'm dying this is crazy
those are the facial expressions you can
see the intensity on anisha's face
what a heartbreaker for Anish I mean
what an absolute Heartbreaker
I feel like everybody's drained after
that
yeah it's like that moment when it all
ends and you can't believe it's over
where's the next game where's the next
source of intrigue a 111 move game
on the heels of which how did Anish
generate chances once he Mouse slipped
Jeffrey let's not forget he was winning
with a fork he did he had two forks
Knight G3 and I think he had Knight H3
winning the F Pawn
but at the end of the day we even saw
them and just decided that nihal's
passers would be too strong at this
point it's all in the past nihal sarin
is the hero of today's match with a
15-14 victory
that might have been the craziest match
of all that definitely competes with an
aronian and draken doesn't it
oh for sure
and I might be biased but I would say it
was even more intense no I agree I agree
that that was that was absolutely crazy
we have another overtime and nihal sarin
ends the match with a ridiculously
clutch save folks do not go anywhere
because the cherry on top is an
interview with nihal sarin so make sure
to spam the chat with your best
questions some of which we will ask
nihal on the other side of this break
folks interview with Niall star and the
victor of this incredible SEC match
coming your way in just a couple of
minutes stay tuned
foreign
okay when I say chess the first word
that pops into your mind
protect my queen Hikaru intelligence
strategy tactics Toby Maguire oh my God
you saw Pawn sacrifice if you're on
Tinder and you're scrolling and someone
has a chess player on their profile as
that swipe left or swipe right
it's like bright is good right yeah then
yeah instant swipe right okay super into
that right I'm into it you're ready
that's probably whatever the swipe is I
don't not interested so you're not
interested in chess players I'm not
interested chess players around Tinder
oh I get that I in fact that checks out
if I ask you to name one chess player in
the world can you name a chess player
yep no not gonna honestly the joy
Capital boy
if you name five other world champions
in the next 15 seconds I'm Gonna Give
You fifty dollars
spasky holgar
Carlson and
on holy you get 50 bucks dude oh my
God we just lost 50 whose idea was that
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the speed Chess
Championship unfortunately uh Newhall
did have some tech issues we had a hard
time getting them on the call so we
decided guess what it's 2 A.M in India
he's just played one of the matches of
his life we will give him a little bit
of time to rest so we apologize for not
bringing you the interview but Jeffrey I
think you'll second me on this there has
been enough entertainment today to last
us probably many months
that would yeah to put it mildly I mean
this is probably one of the most
exciting matches I've ever seen in any
SEC or jscc history it literally had
everything you had runs on both sides
just crazy I mean went down to the wire
couldn't ask for more
we literally couldn't and it went down
to the tie break they went back and
forth in the tie break ultimately
winning that critical game
with the black pieces Anish Mouse
slipping a peace recapture and then
still managing to come back from a pawn
down end game to produce very serious
winning chances he had those chances
until the very very end but ultimately
an amazing save in that Rook end game by
Niall star and who demonstrates nerves
of Steel let's take one more look at our
bracket our updated bracket as nihal
sarin will face dingley Ren and Jeffrey
what's crazy is that this is yet another
rematch from yet another cgc match in
which Niels are in Rand dingley ran out
of the gym as you once said how cool is
that
yeah it feels like complete deja vu
um I do remember this match where I
think it was just before
uh quarterfinals if I'm not mistaken and
yeah it was like
just uh I mean it was just crazy to put
words uh like just based on what you
said it I mean he ran him out of the gym
and I'm sure that Ding will be hungry
for Revenge I'm sure he will be as well
now I said this entertainment should
last you for a couple of months it won't
need to last you a couple months because
it'll actually need to last you a couple
of hours because we have a double header
tomorrow if you have two more SEC
matches coming your way starting with
Wesley so against Notre Beck Abdus
that's coming your way tomorrow Thursday
at 6 00 a.m Pacific 9 00 a.m eastern
time and that will be immediately
followed by one of the Marquee matchups
that everybody's looking forward to
Hikaru Nakamura will finally be making
his SCC debut against David perravian
the qualifier who is not an easy
opponent at all that will follow the
first match at 10 A.M Pacific 1 p.m New
York time and 7 P.M Central European
Time mark your calendars folks you will
be pegged by the computer all day long
as we have an amazing double header
tomorrow
oh my God Jeffrey it's gonna be a feast
tomorrow and I don't know if you can
wait I certainly can't wait for tomorrow
man aren't we spoiled nowadays it just
feels like chess chess chess every day
double header tomorrow
insane action Donya as always it's been
a pleasure you're amazing at your job
and
have just an incredible amount of fun
thank you Jeffrey I did as well before
we go one more shout out uh Market
calendars once again for the second
annual chess kid All-Star finals which
is coming your way on December 17th
that's 10 days from now the world's top
Juniors who won the chess good monthly
championships in 2022 we'll be competing
for the title of Chess kid of the year
they can also win fun prizes like
lessons with Grandmasters and merch from
our store chess gets own fun Master Mike
Klein will hold down the six rounds of
the match on chess TV and the chess kid
twitch Channel tune in December 17th at
9 00 a.m Pacific noon eastern time for
the second annual chess kit All-Star
finals but Jeffrey it is likewise a
pleasure you're a beast nobody I'd
rather cover the match with this was
such a great time I'd like to thank
everybody in the chat for cheering on
your favorite player we had tens of
thousands of you the chat was super high
energy and of course uh our wonderful
team at chess.com for another Flawless
broadcast folks we will see you tomorrow
bright and early for the round of 16
double better Wesley so against Notre
Beck Hikaru against David farabian so
make sure to wake up Brew up your coffee
and enjoy these two matches but for now
we wish you a great rest of your
Wednesday from the speed Chess
Championship we will see you tomorrow on
Thursday for the doubleheader thank you
everybody and goodbye
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]